all right and we are live the last word
would lord cognito and ibontes fresh on
that thursday evening campfire lot going
on in the world of destiny controversy
and a cool guest but let's start with
ibartus first how we doing sir uh doing
good uh stream today messing around with
a little iron banner working on a little
bit of that just kind of keeping up with
the trash fire that is destiny twitter
right now which is entertaining we will
talk about the uh
twab
that uh
sparked a little bit of controversy you
could say
uh and that's all coming off of the
hypeness that is a new witch queen
trailer that they dropped uh i guess one
other day ago basically during
maintenance so kind of basically been
keeping up with all of that i finished
inscription that game is just absolutely
bonkers
like the places that thing goes yeah
pretty much yeah mind-blowing uh mess
around monster hunter rise last night
and then trying to decide if i want to
play that a little more or jump in
horizon zeroed on so
mix it up a little bit on the side but
yeah destiny's keeping me pretty busy
with this week what about you travis
what are you uh
what excitement is coming to the life of
the uh
the man of all the games
yeah i uh
i'm in a weird position where i can't
play destiny right now
um i'm currently on that grind where i
have to do dares of eternity and if i
play any other activity i'll lose my
streak for dares of eternity and i'm
trying to do like five dares a day to
get me there and this is hours of
grinding guys it's like at least 15
hours of grinding together and so i
don't want to have to just like lose two
or three full days this is not a really
an option for me uh because i have other
games to work on so i have to just do
dares and when somebody goes yo travis
jump into this trials card with me i'm
like bro i'm not going to lose five runs
of their fraternity worth of xp just to
get my streak back
that's like an hour of playing dares
that i didn't need to do so i'm not
gonna do that i'm not jumping into any
other activities guys like if you want
to play with me and destiny this week
too bad i'm not losing my streak
i'm doing those dares of eternity until
i get to max rank and then i'm never
going to play that dumb mode again
uh so i'm i'm uh my relationship with
destiny is very toxic right now um and
if that weren't enough uh my my twitter
this week exploded because i decided to
tweet my opinion about vault space
and the internet was not happy with it
i'm talking hundreds of retweets
thousands of likes thousands of it was
hundreds of comments it was
unbelievable what did you say
he was like we just i told him that we
don't need more vault space and they
need to learn to delete stuff that's it
like
it's
here's here's my problem with vault
space all right if we're going to be
real i'll be real
i have so many things to say to people
in the comments that i didn't say
because i don't argue with people on the
internet it's just never productive
it's like no
we gave you you have 500 slots in your
vault space and let me tell you if we
doubled that to a thousand that wouldn't
be enough it's never gonna be enough
you're never gonna be happy you're never
gonna be like oh i have enough vault
space which means bungie has two options
one
they can fix the damn collection screen
and make it the thing it's actually
supposed to be which i've always been an
advocate yeah i've always said that
that's what they should do instead of
vaulting yes or they could just admit
that you're never going to be able to
keep all your stuff and you need to
learn to stop being a hoarder and just
get rid of it i had people in my
comments with the audacity to tell me
to tell me that i'm playing the game
wrong if i'm not collecting all the
weapons well let me tell you let me tell
you guys let me tell you
only one of our styles of playing the
game literally is impossible
because bungie won't let you play it the
way that you want to because they're not
giving travis's opinions do not reflect
those of the last words
i hate puppies and children
look look if either of us
look if either of us is playing the game
wrong wouldn't it be the person who
literally can't play the game that they
want to in the game like you're
literally saying i can't play the game i
want and you're telling me i'm playing
it wrong maybe you should look in the
mirror and and get some reflection
get do do something
does it does this weapon spark joy and
if it doesn't hold that x button that's
all i have to say marie
that's [ __ ] you need to delete your
vault stuff that's all i can say i have
no no further questions at least it was
after five minutes
i'm sorry did we play the disclaimer
on it man he's standing i'll jump in
real quick um kind of the driving
situation it's been an insanely busy
week for me as a consecrative but i've
been trying to sneak on
right now it's about doing that cleanup
work prior to the new expansion i need
to get my galley catalyst i need to get
my halfway through my armless catalyst
being complete oh like you gotta have
that that's yeah that's a beautiful
weapon now
yeah you know that's gonna be endgame so
i'm trying to work on that so i've been
sneaking on for a few like an hour when
i can but to be honest you oh trav it's
halo infinite multiplayer has actually
been
what i can sustain a quick burst match
and i'll i'll i'll get my little ten rye
armor my little samurai armor i get
through the battle pass and then and
then i'm going but i'll be back
hopefully shout out to dj in the chat
we're gonna get that dungeon i gotta get
my galley cat lost the catalyst done but
um that that's what i got and um we got
a special guest we gotta
be patient while we've been talking all
right
it's fine i'm fine everything's fine
welcome
oh no hold on
you might be better right now
welcome to the last word episode 180.
the coals have been put on the fire the
hype train has left the station and will
only be picking up steam in the weeks to
come
as we all pull out our old chemistry
books from high school and google has
its highest search requests for osmium
possibly ever we really are in
pre-expansion hype 2022 is looking to be
a great year for at least video games
and destiny is included in that list for
sure
and who better to be our first guest
this year than someone very well
equipped to talk about the odd
cross-section of all things destiny and
science this lady started her gaming
journey just watching it first but we
can thank her dad for the gaming
introduction
what game was it you ask it was halo of
course that got the gaming ball rolling
the action the magic it had the hooks in
early and why wouldn't it space science
fiction it all called to her and boy did
she answer she took her love of the
universe the unknown and computers and
somehow funneled that into the perfect
job nasa yeah that one and i'll say it
again a nasa software engineer oh that's
cute that's a cute bug in your game we
can't have bugs because if we had bugs
it would cause a 10 billion dollar crash
and could waste 10 years of planning old
school code releases and no day one
patches here so let's welcome the
co-host of the spin foil theory podcast
destiny lore
encyclopedia hi vroon expert see i told
you it was a perfect show to have her on
rage sherpa and a hot cocoa addict the
one the only lady lucida good evening
and welcome to what i would expect to be
a very spicy show how you doing
doing pretty good pretty good like you
said uh
yeah
i
do work at nasa that is my real job
[Laughter]
yeah that was when we we asked our our
guests a couple questions you know some
some give us a lot to work with some
give us a little you really needed to
just put the one bullet point on there
nasa software interior everything else
could have been blank and we could have
probably talked about that but um
can i open with a question that's
related to nasa absolutely go for it go
for it when something is easy at nasa
what did they say to convey that it's
easy because they can't say it's not
rocket science
i just say i just say that's not rocket
science
why did you say that come on that's not
rocket science what are you doing
yeah well because basically so
what i do particularly is i don't
necessarily work with like the rockets
and everything else what i do is more
with the theoretical astrophysics okay
so like we simulate planets we simulate
climate
what i did actually pretty recently and
by rece i looked at my imaginary watch
here
all theoretical right
that was good
that was good that was good but
but relatively recently i published a
scientific publication
that is the culmination of the last five
years of research wow so
can you give us a um
gamers understanding level yeah tldr for
the average non-rocket scientist but for
the layman
i can i can dumb it down a couple levels
um basically what we did is we um
so with earth how we have the polar caps
if you and we have the polar caps
because earth has a slight tilt that's
called the obliquity
the obliquity also causes the seasons if
you increase the obliquity instead of it
being
23.5 if you increase it to like 90
instead of there being ice on the poles
there's ice along the equator and what
we call an ice belt
so basically what my publication and
what i did was i mapped the parameter
space of the
ice of polar caps and ice belts
and then also on the other end of the
spectrum is what we call a snowball
planet you guys have seen star wars yeah
you guys know the planet yeah of course
we have some guy who hated it
if you say star wars you just lost the
rest of the
podcast
it's going to go somewhere very quickly
no no it's good he's very happy right
now
well because basically a snowball planet
is basically like like hoth like you
don't want to live
there you don't want to live
on a planet that's it's like it's kind
of like i would i don't want to say like
a goldilocks situation because that's a
that's a misnomer yeah but
that's that's never been done before
like the kind of research i did
mapping that parameter space so that was
really cool and then because of that
doing that research i ended up getting
oh i'm sure yeah
yeah i would have had yourself a little
bit of yeah yeah a lot of math and a lot
of physics
it seems like a europa kind of situation
yeah pretty much pretty much
i could have also said like europa but
i figured hoth people have seen star
wars so you know
we get it but yeah that's that's
basically yeah i just finished that up
people in the world know what hoth is
than europa
yes
and then if you and then if you say
that's a good yeah then if you say in
cell enceladus you'll just lose them all
mm-hmm
they're all just like what yeah is that
a word
uh so i wanted to ask like
so
[Music]
take earth tip it not so we're 90
degrees as you were saying so there
would actually be an ice belt would
earth theoretically still be
habitable habitable
or is it more like i guess it would
depend on because if like this is gonna
sound bad if the south pole if it tilted
say if that's what was facing the sun
the entire time
would but the north pole would
you know i'm trying to figure out i'm
asking too many questions at the same
time i guess eastern
yeah the east and west pole would the
east pole theoretically always be facing
the sun so then
would the other how would that work out
of curiosity
how would that work that's a great
question you're like yeah that was the
five years of research go read it
that wasn't fun though no it's fine it's
fine
well no so basically
how it works is that
because well we varied a bunch of
different parameters so we varied
obliquity that's you know pretend this
is the the axial tilt so you know we
varied this from
zero all the way to 90. we also varied
what's called the eccentricity and
that's the like shape of the orbit okay
and
so like if it's
zero then it's a perfect circle if it's
closer to one then it's more oval i'm
giving a science lesson i guess you guys
didn't no no trust me i'd love science
like i would
do this all day for this yes
oh no what have i done
and then we also varied the semi-major
axis and then we varied the spectral
type of the star too to see how that
affected habitability like red giant or
anything like that
yeah
we did our star which is a g type a g
dwarf and then we did one below which is
we did f which is one above
g which is r star and then k which is
one below in like classification of
stars
so we just we did our sun made a little
bit bigger and a little bit smaller we
didn't do m dwarfs because m dwarfs are
or are cringe sorry nope you're good
they're not actually cringe but they're
just one person got that joke
yes one person got that joke okay that's
a good one
that's okay that's better than zero
i'm making progress but yeah basically
with that we ended up
finding that ice belts are more common
than polar caps for some pla for some
spectral types which is like
that's weird
so earth really does tend to be a bit
more unique than we think sometimes
yeah definitely i mean to sum up besides
the fact that
tld
yes that's why we are number one we're
the best
because that we know of
that we know exactly that we know i mean
i'm
in the camp that there's probably
intelligent life somewhere out there in
the universe but we just space is really
[ __ ] big
really big like
i don't think people don't realize how
big space is it's really really big
yeah so
yeah getting bigger all the time yeah
literally never never stopping getting
everybody ever expanding red shift right
yeah i was gonna ask um
right after that oh what's up song
like just because of your background and
and obviously what you do is these are
the reasons kind of like that made you
gravitate towards but we're gonna get in
destiny but your history initial history
was actually the halo right your dad and
stuff like that so talk about that talk
about what gravitated you to watching
this and kind of getting into that game
as your precursor to destiny as my
precursor to destiny yes
i don't know i just thought it was like
super cool and i've always loved like
sci-fi like i loved star i love star
wars i love like all of the like sci-fi
stuff and that was the first time
because i didn't like when i was younger
i didn't really know what video games
were like
that's just how it was like
in my house i guess because like video
games were like a new thing when i was
growing up i'm not like
a new new thing but like xbox like the
360 was coming out and that and that
kind of stuff so
i i just i remember my dad playing it on
like his work laptop which was so funny
he was like i'm using my government
laptop
and i was just always i would always sit
there and just be like i don't know
what's happening but i think it looks
cool like i didn't understand the story
i didn't understand anything i'm just
like master chief go pew pew okay that's
cool
and then i really like started paying
attention like with when i actually
played like halo 2
and you got to flip between playing as
master chief and then playing arbiter
that that was cool i know a lot of
people like later on were like no
orbiter's operator's korean but no i i
think orbiter is cool i like him he's
probably like one of my favorite
helicopters
he's cool he's the best
[Music]
so easy
so then you continued on and then i
wanted to deal with your halo journey
yeah and then
i remember
playing halo reach in like middle school
ish i actually have a funny story we
just got older
let's go
yes
yes i'm sorry i think everyone feel old
i'm sorry
but we're old and stupid tonight so we
just checking all the boxes it's good
just check all the boxes sorry no but um
i remember my mom
was in disneyland and my dad called her
and was like hey can we get an xbox and
she's like i'm literally she i think she
was like on a ride or something
and she was like i what what are you
talking about and he's like okay thanks
bye and then he hung up and then he just
bought the xbox that's the dad way to do
it hey
this point in time where you can't
really answer i need to ask you this
question if i can buy something cool
okay bye
pretty much that happened and then she
came back and we had an xbox and she's
like
what
what
what is this
it was really funny and then
i started playing halo reach i really
like halo reach it's probably one of my
favorite halo games
i took my friend the other day who had
never played halo reach through the
campaign and he was like wow this is
actually
pretty good
it was really funny though because so
for those of you who haven't played it
there's a part where you fly where you
go into space and my friend little's
like it's just gonna be a cutscene we're
not actually gonna fly around in space
right
i literally had to like mute my mic and
i was like oh
you don't know what's about to happen
y'all knows about that
he didn't know anything you want to do
it completely blind like he knew like
people died but that's all he knew right
he didn't know anything else so
i think
i think halo reaches it's still like
good today which says a lot
about like the quality of the game i
know it was bungie's last
halo game that they ever worked on
and that
that part always made me curious like
when i remember like playing it when i
was growing up
when it was like
the most recent halo game when that they
were saying this is the last one i was
like so is halo done right what is
bungie going to work on next and then it
was it was destiny the transition oh
yeah look at me i like that i liked it
right for travis
yeah it's beautiful
i uh i'm also a big halo fan
a little bit um
yeah very big very big
although i haven't had as much time to
play multiplayer as uh coghouse this
past month unfortunately
despite my best efforts um but you're
right cog it is easy to log on to halo
and i uh i kind of missed that about it
um at destiny it's like you gotta figure
out your armor loadout and your your
weapon loadout and there's like all this
work you have to do before you can hop
into a trials card and you don't have to
deal with an alo which is beautiful um
yeah i guess uh my question is um what
what drew you to halo and destiny was it
the space association was it something
like that or yeah basically was like the
sci-fi
aesthetic
i just like space i think it's cool with
gunplay
yeah definitely bungie yeah bungie
definitely knows their guns i love the
needler it's my favorite
oh yeah it really is it really is i love
it
needle or gober as i like to say
i'm really sad
yeah i really liked the needle rifle in
uh
reach that was probably like because
this basically was like a dmr and a
needle or had a baby and it was
beautiful that was so beautiful reach is
definitely one of my least favorite
halos but lots of people really like it
you know what's weird
people your people your age tend to like
halo reach a lot um
for me halo 2 was my favorite but it
also came out at like that critical
period where like that was yeah the
dopest thing that ever come out and halo
reach came out when i was it was like
the year i graduated college or
something and i was sort of like for me
it was loadouts that was the thing i
didn't really like in halo reach
multiplayer the addition of loadouts and
all the armor lock controversy that was
so cheesy the whole armament yeah that's
true yeah it just had lots of stuff that
didn't hit it for me i still really like
the campaign but
um something about halo 2
and how much it developed the world and
gave the covenant its motives and
developed the arbiter and had that
before like that'll always be my
favorite campaign i think so
um but yeah uh
yeah i definitely agree with that so so
let's go to destiny then um
how
how did you get into destiny when was
the first time you played did you play
during the beta or the alpha or
something like that and uh
what character class did you gravitate
to initially and are you still that
character
that's an interesting question so
i remember i played the beta cause i was
like oh
it's made by the same people who made
halo
okay i'll try it let's let's see what
this is about i remember playing with
all my friends
and we all i got let's like max level in
the beta and i made a huncher and a
warlock i don't think i made a titan i
don't remember you're fine you're fine
no need
i'm being messy continue i'm being messy
i'm
i'm always surrounded by titans i gotta
throw my shots when i get them no it's
right it's fine
and um i picked hunter specifically
because like you know how when you hover
over the class when you're making them
it shows like the little description yes
of it i didn't care for golden gun i was
like golden gun that sounds terrible i
saw blade dancer with the invis and i'm
like okay okay
okay i like i like being invisible that
sounds cool
and then
for warlock i really liked nova bomb
yeah i thought that was cool it's hard
not to like no have you noticed there's
a lady at a void have you noticed when
npcs
do cool things in cinematics
it's nova bomb
most of the time outside of a bubble
because you got like blowing stuff up
that's cool even
doing the same damn thing like that's
the which one she's going to pick she
went warlock void super
i'm like alright
just it looks cool yeah it just looks
cool it is kind of ultra destruction
yeah you get to throw a thunder crash
pretty much pretty much but yeah no
definitely
and then
flash forward to today i'm
i'm in this a weird i wouldn't say
predicament but kind of this weird
where i've gotten to the point where
i've played destiny so goddamn much that
i can be any class any stop like it
doesn't matter yeah i can be whatever
your omni-class got to that point where
i'm omni i am all the classes but no
because like
because i'm i'm i'm now what whatever my
team needs me to be which normally is
titan
unfortunately
oh no that's that's what she said
slander is welcome tite's land is always
welcome here i mean like
it's not free speaking
i just
i feel like i have to be someone has to
be titan in my group because we always
have a lot of we have a
massive amount of hunters everyone likes
hunters everyone likes hunters
and with this season especially with um
particle deconstructions hunters are
kind of
useless yeah they really are no they are
like hunters they're just they're just
literally useless like you're tethered
total deconstruction doesn't do anything
yeah
or make sure deconstruction
debuffs more than tether and you can
proc it
more often you don't need to use a super
yup
guess what golden gun with celestial i
can out dps you with a thunder crash
adios hunters are useless
sorry
so a lot of people have been like i
guess our main
it's just that's just math i'm sorry i'm
sorry do not challenge this lady in the
math department she will win
no no it's fine but so more often than
not i
bite the bullet and um the bubble titan
i mean i like void on all the three
classes void is my favorite so i'm very
very excited for void 3.0 i'm very
excited
i'm very excited because then i can take
like
i could basically take blade dancer
and make it grape flavored because
assuming well that's literally what
spectral blades is it's literally blade
dancer but
grapefruit i've got an advanced gg
flavor for you it's called grist
that's hilarious
so then assuming it works kind of the
same way where you can choose your melee
and grenade and they did they said
they're not getting rid of this forsaken
supers they're just gonna
be reworked into that i wish they would
give us a little bit more information so
we know what to expect though oh we're
gonna be the thieves show today yeah
we're gonna get some communication that
is a clear classic put a pin in that one
that's the final topic is the world of
bungee communication
but yes oh they're in
non-communication
yeah yeah
that yeah but i'm just really excited
because like for me i love nova warp
and i was like wait can i take devourer
and nova warp
and put it together yeah yeah that'd be
sweet that sounds terrifying to be on
the other end
yeah totally yeah don't then pvp like
i'm really curious to see like how cause
like the stasis has so much
customizability
i'm curious to see how
what we have now
for like the void subclasses is going to
translate
to
the void 3.0 i'm with you i'm hoping
it's cool because i mean same thing with
titans and i said i think even with void
3.0 like the titan bubble
super is going to shift up to tier 5
because it is kind of gonna work the
same way as well of radiance but just
the mixing and matching because for a
titan
sentinel the big shield is
functional for like
nightfalls basically it's not like
you're gonna pop that in a raid but the
grenade functionality of like the chain
explosions is always so much fun and i'm
like can i have a bubble and chain
explosion that's all i want like as a
void titan i just want those two
together if i can put those two pretty
much everything else is fine and then if
i gotta have shoulder charge to go with
that like i'm hoping the customization
that like we think is going to be there
is there but again we'll get to it
bungie always kind of doing these half
step measures i have a little
reservation about being
like full dive into void 3.0 until i see
it but crossing my fingers they get that
one right
yeah i agree i'm a little
i'm excited because you know
thinking of all of the different
customizations we can do and like the
builds yeah the belts
that's what i'm looking forward to but
at the same time
i'm also like uh
i don't know about this because like
we're gonna have to probably lose
something some stuff yeah
to gain this stuff if that makes sense i
would agree
what are we gonna have to what are we
gonna lose there will be some concession
on some level we just got to figure out
how what it is and if the trade-offs are
exciting
yeah worth it yeah
well that definitely was like that seems
kind of like a perfect time to get into
the official
destiny conversation at this point
so feel free with all of your destiny
knowledge and lore and everything this
is where we are going to kind of tap
into your world of lore and science
the witch queen trailer dropped on
tuesday during maintenance and i was
like hey cool so i can work on this
video okay there's a trailer this video
is now tomorrow damn it that was like my
tuesday morning it was like cool i get a
break work on this video see if i can
get it
tomorrow nevermind see what's on here
break it down frame by frame um
there was a lot of stuff that came out
in there one of them
specifically is the
text
hate like frames when text is on the
screen kind of saying whatever it's
going to say for like her world or
whatever it is they had a little easter
eggs in there and it was all very
scientific alchemy related i saw asda
cross actually had a little bit more
went into like old school alchemy like
lore questions and stuff um
kind of when you talked about and i'll
kind of say what the major ones are
one of them was osmium
and the what they had on there was the
electron configuration which is if you
guys saw like the xe14 and all that
stuff that was the electron
configuration of osmium if you google
those that you're only going to pop up
one thing we had sulfur
which was
was that the
16 how how well do you know your
periodic table
not enough not your expertise that's
that's totally fine not my expertise
physics and math she got you periodic
table should leave that to the chemist
that's why it's why we have multiple
people uh sulfur's one of them yeah and
then now i'm blanking on the other one
even though i've talked about mercury
yeah mercury is the other one
uh so those were the main three
kind of scientific things that people
extracted from the trailer on top of
everything else so outside of the
science which i want to get to in a
second what did you guys what excited
you the most about the trailer that you
saw um and
lucy you can go first of course because
you are a guest what i get to go first
yeah what what hyped you up the most
about the trailer where what's got that
hype train starting to move
i'm
was really excited to like see a little
bit more of savithun's throne world
because i'm probably going to live there
forever it's gonna be my favorite
destination because
the hive are my favorite
and
like taking king was my favorite d1
expansion this is probably gonna be my
favorite d2 expansion come on it's it's
literally the taken king equivalent
in destiny so
um
what i thought was really interesting is
there was one frame where it showed
three guardians walking up their guns
were lowered up to what looks to be like
an injured hive ghost
yeah the one was kind of like the corner
broken off a little bit yeah
yeah i thought that was interesting i
was like
are we gonna
is are we gonna make friends with the
guys is it gonna be our buddy
please i want to be friends with the
hive
i'm i'm like let's be friends with
everyone and then we can all fight the
darkness together we're two thirds of
the way to the avengers pack right now
so
we're two-thirds of the way there and
then not even
are you so sure
no we don't care about the scoring score
they're bad
no
they're bad this is not everybody it's
never going to work if uh if we exclude
if we don't have everything
yeah there's no exclusion in this group
the problem the problem is both the
taken are now directly controlled
by
the winner slash capital d darkness
and same thing with the scorn the scorn
are now also kind of in cahoots with the
darkness so there
and same with zevo wrath like that's
like the enemies and then we have
kaitl's cabal we have house light
we have the blue light vex
which might be our friend don't know if
you guys remember but during the
culmination of season the splicer
off in the left side
there was a little blue there's a little
vex with a little blue light that was
flashing in morse code assistant
i missed that one
yeah
so i think that's pretty
that was interesting and then now we
have seven using the lights right and we
don't really know how that's gonna work
because obviously savathun keeps her
memories we we assume
otherwise she wouldn't really be evil
that would she
right so if there is a way like if there
was a way to either circumvent the whole
regaining their memory sort of thing or
there might be high they're like hey
this might be bad why don't we be trying
being friends i could see that happening
hmm
sort of question i just i just want
they'll go i just want to hive to be our
friends i just want the hive to be our
friends being that you you love the lore
of the hive and everything that's going
on you know one of the talking points
we've had is in reference to me and
travis call it the or is it there we
don't want to ooga booga the situation
you know which means basically we go in
there we're going to throw the world we
kill
you know the guardians did it in that
kind of a bit we kind of want
this build-up to to be respected right
so
our question
to you is do you think
with what we've seen so far and we know
obviously obviously saboteur gets the
light and and everything that
the possibility should be around a bit
longer as opposed to us just kind of
doing our guardian thing and just
thrashing her about and i'd be over it
i definitely think
we're not just it's not just gonna be a
one-and-done
situation that we're just gonna waltz in
there uh
punch savathun in the face
it's done adios we we do a do a dance
and then we leave now i think it's going
to be a lot more
i mean it probably will happen i'll
probably do that when my friends and i
we all kill seven we'll be like ha ha
we'll like do stupid emotes or whatever
because we're stupid but like
i think that
i definitely think because unless we
like
kill her ghost and kill her permanently
but then
that makes us
like
i think this expansion is really gonna
del or delve into like why
what makes us the good guys um
how are we how is what sev thun is doing
any different than what we've been doing
i don't know if you've noticed the sim i
think the symbology of seven's throne
world is really ironic
she has the walls yes she's actually
basically acting as like a speaker
telling what the rest of the guardians
to do
and then if you take that flip to what
we do we have like our walls around our
city
and we had well we had the speaker
kind of leading us and telling us what
to do it's like
and now we're the ones invading
their territory
killing them
and doing all that kind of
stuff that kind of seems bad i mean it's
all about perspective and as savithune
says truth is a funny thing
it's very much like hmm
it's all about perspective
i think
enough fair enough it is a weird thing
of a weird thing of destiny that um
all the bad guys have good guy names
like they're called like knights
and wizards yeah and and then guardians
have like evil names like warlock
and titan
and like you know yeah that are
typically associated with evil so
contour
probably
yeah i think that's probably a remnant
of the original script where you know
like we were supposed to respect the
beginning and they kind of changed it
it's probably just a remnant of that but
i i hope you're right i hope that
sabathian's story is much more complex
than than we're used to i hope that
there's
lots of
kind of interplay of what makes us good
or what makes us bad
unfortunately
after having seen how they handled the
relationship with the darkness and
beyond light i really don't think we're
gonna get that because that was like a
huge
conversation where it should have been
like oh we're using the darkness now
there's this other world where people
are using i talked about this on the
show a couple weeks ago but
there
was such an opportunity for them to
really delve into that and they didn't
do it at all they just sort of like hand
waved and we're like yep you're using
the darkness now it's just a game
mechanic guys like take it easy
um i have a feeling yeah definitely and
then and then from the trailer
i think there was footage of us fighting
sabathune in that
so yeah i think we know at the very
least that there's not going to be any
major surprises like right out the gate
of her not really being the bad guy or
um you know anything like that where
we're hoping for more nuance i i think
it i think it's probably going to play
out exactly in the way we hope it
doesn't where we're going to charge in
and sabaton's going to be like i got the
light that was my master plan and we're
going to be like we don't care and we're
going to kill her and then that's going
to be the whole expansion
i really hope i'm wrong but
i just there's something in my gut
that's telling me that it's going to be
like that and i had the same feeling oh
yeah well they i remember
i remember reading like one of the uh
the interviews
that
i think it was with joe
blackburn where they talked about they
don't want to just have it be a
one-and-done with savathune
so
hopefully that helps helps like ease you
a little bit yeah
but
it's just like it's been like look at
what look yeah look at what happened to
aramis i mean like it's technically not
a one and done but she's basically been
frozen for what
yeah exactly
that's what they mean if that's what
they mean that it's not a one on done
because they're gonna put her on ice for
a later expansion put another cocoon you
know you know what you know what else
wasn't it
you don't know what else wasn't a
one-on-done is crota because we're still
fighting him and dares of eternity
everybody
the past seven years have
kind of got our expectations where they
are we have some hype we have some
reservations but again as you're saying
it's like do we think this can be the
campaign that is like
the campaign for destiny
previous history tells
us generally no
but
part of me has at least a bit of hope
because
beyond light
season the hunt was kind of like
kind of had to get this one out felt
like that might have been which like it
seemed like the
the in-between expansion once we got it
once we knew which queen and more was
coming it wasn't it told a weird it told
an odd story that i have no idea what
we're going to get back to
sabbath is the bigger piece
and i think the weight that savann has
plus when we got to see how storytelling
had chosen and then splicer and now and
lost
the growth of the narrative team seeing
literally some of the narrative people
on twitter like
can't wait to see like what when you
know when you guys get to see get your
hands on this one
again like the history has me like big
reservations but i've seen enough that i
was like
if they are going to try and deliver a
campaign especially as we're going to
have like replayability to the campaign
with higher difficulties and things of
that nature and they mentioned they want
the campaign to have pieces of like
dungeons and other things there's like
one of those interviews that says it's
all the cool secret mission stuff that
we've had before we want to have pieces
of those in the campaign it feels like
it does have potential to be different
if they can deliver and that's the big
thing is like they can have a lot of
talk but will they actually deliver on
it and i think that's kind of some of
the interesting things is we see
savathun in the trailer she throws a
nova bomb i think there's gonna be proof
of hey we go into a realm and we get
just you know shellacked dead and we get
revived and maybe sent back to the tower
and be like all right that didn't work
we gotta
regroup and like try again so it's like
there's gonna be probably some
understanding of she is the light maybe
one tease of one of the guardians and
then we might face those but there's got
to be a point where
sabathune in her throne world
right yet we know and they've told us
the raid boss is not savithoon
and if she is not a one and done
then
i have this weird speculation either
she's going to be asking for her help to
go clear kill something in her
raid world that maybe she can't deal
with maybe it's some ultimate evil maybe
it's her worm or the representation of
her worm i don't know like but it does
feel like it's going to be some if they
do it well at least i should say right
but again like if they connect like the
crota to regicide to king's fall
if they can get us to the campaign
to something to the raid boss having
meaning between all this it's got
potential and i think they've set up
these cards long enough if they don't
deliver now like i was see this um
steven said it pretty well
if we kill another god in a strike i
will actually riot
yeah if that happens i'm gonna be like
yeah that that's going to be like a five
it's they can't do that again
yeah i mean
i agree
i think that um
yeah there's a lot of pressure there's a
lot of cost for them to execute but i'm
with you like i said the the the last
year from the narrative team really gave
me a lot of confidence on building
stories and intertwining
all these different pieces these chess
pieces to this moment right the only
complaint we had was just that we knew
this you know which queen was delayed so
we had this big gap but it wasn't really
their fault it would just say they had
to deal with it so we just kind of been
stuck in pause but
after seeing the trailer yeah i'm
excited first i want to shout out
i love deborah wilson like she just
she's
she she makes me uncomfortable at savage
and even like we were talking about
during the season when you you do your
quest steps for the week and it's like
your friend sabathoon wants to talk to
you at the like that used to make me
uneasy like i've always said that then
you have that conversation and she's
always one step ahead she's always
the cunningness and and for me that's
why i'm so dying to know
with this mara situation how she dupes
this whole seance and gets free like i
need so many questions answered so i'm
excited for that but to the trailer
itself i think what i'm hoping for like
you said eve
respect the character
give us a little bit more than just a
straightforward you know we're going to
do the thing
you know kind of thing and also i like
the aspect of deception and they were
kind of playing around with that in the
throne world and showing different
images and it correct me if i was
thinking i thought i saw orrick's statue
in the back doing something or
knocking it yeah i'm like i like this i
want because i agree you know what lucy
says that like we gotta admit like
taking taking king was like
that that was excellent and hive as far
as you know yeah as far as as far as our
enemy race they have some of the the
best law let's just call it what is
there probably the more interesting
enemy type than all of them so i'm
hoping we get more backstory with that
those relationships i'm curious about
this evil erad thing where that's gonna
go are we gonna get deep into that are
they saving that for later but the last
thing i'll say is
the pyramid ship
i i gotta know what's going on i gotta
know what's going my mind that's my
curiosity with the with the space
doritos has not that thirst
not being quenched we've been yeah we
heard space doritos once and we can't
get rid of that by the way let's just
start playing
i think it's great what are their whole
thing with sabbath doing i need to know
and i just i hope they execute but you
know i got i've got a little hope i got
a little hope but you know that they
might pull this stuff together but we'll
see
yeah definitely
i'm just kind of terrified
from staring at the the you know cracked
open pyramid ship inside savathun's
throne world you guys don't realize mara
solved through everything at the
pyramids nothing
rasputin threw everything he had
at the pyramids nothing astr i'm pretty
sure asher like shot a nuke or something
at the pyramids on io
nothing well the fact that savathun has
something that can just crack a pyramid
open
like uh
uh
that's bad that's really bad
like so do you think so here's a
question do you actually think that
that's a legitimate pyramid in her
throne world because my question would
be how would a pyramid ship get into
her throne world because it isn't her
throne world kind of of her own creation
true but you have to remember
we know that the first mission takes
place on mars yes
and we know that there was a pyramid
ship that ate mars for breakfast
basically
so it's possible that savathun was able
to do
something to like
invert
the pyramid ship so to speak where
basically the pyramid ship goes in her
throne world or something we don't know
that's the that's i'm kind of like
looking at that pyramid ship like uh
no
no
no no nobody no just back away you know
because like the darkness freaks me out
man it's scary
i kind of think that it's uh
it's not a real
pyramid you know what i mean you don't
think it's really it's fake yeah i kind
of think it's metaphorical or represents
something in her mind her connection to
the darkness or her
uh past or i could definitely see that
or something and i think if we if the
raid takes place there it'll probably be
like what is sabathun afraid of like
that's the thing that we're going to go
in yeah
[Music]
yeah yeah i
pretty sure
the raid does take place on
yeah they've said that
we know that and then it'll be like now
that you've killed savathune figure out
what's happening she's not dying
she better not die in the strike mission
now that you've killed savathune during
the three-hour campaign
yes
come play the raid and kill the darkness
and that is the end of that
that better not be the market but i see
that as the bullet point
yeah
well because yeah because they say um
quote um among the swamps of sabathun's
throne world lies a sunken pyramid along
your fire team venture inward and
confront the ancient danger imprisoned
with it
that's why i wondered on the ancient
danger somebody in my chat had mentioned
that it was um
possibly like her worm
of some kind because i know we're trying
to split her from her worm but that's
what she wants separation from so what
does she fear
or like the attachment to it maybe it's
like kind of her i don't know that's
somebody said that i was like i don't
picture it being the worm but i was like
at least the scale of a worm would be
fitting of a raid boss if it's not
killed with just the strike mechanic
i think it'd be really funny if the
final boss of the witch green wade was
tanex's legs y'all don't even start
don't put no tan don't put that evil on
me
i've had enough attacks i love them but
i've had enough fam
you you
[Music]
her nephew is the ancient evil she's
terrified of her nephew
this dude he just got crazy maybe
assuming
assuming it's not
like her worm i don't think it's her
worm that's fair and assuming the
pyramid
ship isn't like some like
fake imaginative thing if it's real
then i'm thinking
the enemies in the raid are either going
to be scorned or taken that's my guess
okay probably because
it's
kind of suspicious that bungie added you
know scorned champions when the
nightfall yeah it's going away yep has
scorned champions is going away it's
like huh why would you that's weird why
would you put it in this world
why
exactly why would you put in this
unnecessary work adding in
all of these assets and stuff just to
thanos snap it out of existence in a
couple months like
that doesn't see i know bungie's trying
to be a lot smarter with their
resources and that sort of thing
so
my assumption is either going to be
taken or scored maybe a combination of
the two something like that i mean we've
already had a taken raid before with
last wish so i'm leaning more towards
scorn
but or hive i mean yeah something like
that because we haven't ever had a scorn
right scorn hasn't
we've also seen pictures of i guess it's
from bungie's uh press releases where
there's pictures and in the trailer
there was scorn in sabbath stone world
so there's definitely scoring in there
for sure yeah quick question before we
move on from the last i have lucy um
over under survival
mara
osiris
do they make it to which creed
i need to know from you
i do all right break it down i'm gonna
start with fanboy tell you because i
know i know
i know
i actually know yes i have secret future
knowledge okay no she reads i
i read i can read no i'm getting it
because i'm real satisfying wait it's
looking spooky for my man so i i need to
know
i need to know i'm asking what's to
happen well
do you want me to spoil it though oh i'm
good
i can be vague
okay um
how do i be vague um
i guess i'll say this bungie would be
really really stupid
to
go through
because it's a very common trope it's
called the barry you're gay stroke
and i know bungie's very no it's it's an
actual trope in like media where like
you know
there's these gay characters and one of
them dies for character development it
happens a lot it's really bad and i hate
it
so
and bungie's very inclusive so i would
highly
dislike
that would be really stupid if they did
that how about your days how about barry
obey
[Applause]
safe would like that too like i mean
i mean it's also kind of kind of poetic
if you kind of think about it from this
way where say osiris went through so
much effort to get saint back i'm going
that's why i'm going having seen the
same thing
yeah i think i
he'll i think he'll be okay i think
everything will be fine i think
sabathune will actually
pull through and do up uphold her end of
the bargain but at the last second be
like bye i'm out okay okay adios mara is
maura because there's there's a
prevailing theory in the community shout
out i've got to mention it shout out my
boy wilhelm scream he listens to us a
lot as well and trap there is
there's a train of thought that there's
been mara solving sovereignty and all
the same
you know what he stand on that and then
the whole
if they're not the same which i feel
they're not the same um is maura
gonna be able to survive this eventual
we know
cyber thune is gonna beat whatever it is
at the end of this season of the lost
stuff that she got going on with the
sean
it finally arrives it's been 84 years
well no because like i was like okay
it's gotta be this week and then nothing
okay it's gotta be this one that's me
too
two weeks before the end of the season
is what i'm guessing so hold your breath
yeah it's probably going to be february
first
probably that week just go
but you think what's happening
talk to me what you're thinking i think
that i mean yes i do bungie likes their
i guess using their mirrors with how you
know mara
mirror savathun they've made that
an uh analogy a lot
i do think mara though is
i wouldn't say too important of a
character just to die okay she
definitely
personally i think because i know people
have been saying you know with the
spoiler alert hand or sidearm coming
back people are like oh somebody's gonna
die because the narrative team said yeah
someone's gonna die i mean
you could be really obvious and be like
well savathun's technically died right
technically yeah technically yes correct
but
some people i i think spiders gonna die
oh i mean no mara already has a hitman
squad on it like like she literally said
to petra after we're done with this
whole savathune thing get a kill squad
ready for spider yeah yeah she lives
that long
yeah i guess that's true i don't know i
knew she was out here
this lady thinks that she
do you do you remember vanilla destiny's
campaign i feel like everyone was on my
side back then because she was like the
the most annoying part of the campaign
where she's like oh i'm a queen i don't
like you guardians go and do my bidding
oh in the beginning yeah she was
obnoxious yeah i didn't know that
but i think i think she rose a little
bit of fame at taking king when she had
a moment
aren't you guys a little annoyed by her
in season of the lost like the way she
tried to grow and the way she treats you
and the way she's so arrogant about
sabbath dude she's like oh i know what
i'm doing and i'll get my servant petra
to do things for me everything about her
has made me not like her and i feel like
if she died i'd kind of be like well now
i like sabbath a little bit more to be
honest oh so i kind of hope she does
personally they all have it again you
can't find they think okay i'm sorry i
definitely think
that
we've gotten a little more
of mara's character this season we've
definitely seen her
like
i feel like she has like this mask that
she wears around everybody that's very
much like
she has to be strong because she feels
like she's the only person who can do
this
and sometimes
there's been little there's been little
moments here and there where you can see
like the stress is getting to her she's
kind of she's snapped a couple times at
a cora at
that conversation they had within the
cocoon girl that was serious
it was like you're putting on that face
but i know what's going on sorry katie
yeah no no no you're absolutely right
and
i think
the main reason she doesn't like
guardians so much is like
especially in the beginning when
mara and the rest of her
people kind of came back to the soul
system
and
like they only had a very small amount
of people with them and then
a good chunk of them was like you know
what we're gonna go help earth and she's
like we should help ourselves first and
then go help earth and then
those people leave those people die they
become guardians or not some of them
didn't and then
they
lose i guess
mara's biggest thing is she very much
likes being in control yeah she's kind
of a control freak yes very much
she has her like
she has her plans and i mean also you
have to think about it us
we
like the players we know mara's plan
isn't gonna work we've seen the witch
queen trailers like in universe nobody
knows sure they they don't have guardian
tv where they can watch the witch queen
they don't know
they don't know they don't know they
don't have future knowledge like we do
so like
if pretending like we don't know that
sava thune is gonna
say betray but like
pull a switcheroo yeah there's gonna be
some last second like last second slight
of hand for her to get out of there yeah
it seems like that but yeah definitely i
i don't know i'm just kind of like
i definitely feel like this season has
added a lot of character tomorrow and i
hope
by the end of it
she kind of comes to an understanding
with crow
because i know like right now she's very
conflicted she's even said so herself
that she's really been conflicted
because even the whole time like while
she was queen she's like one of her
voices was like the queen in me wanted
to keep aldrin's at arm length but the
sister in me wanted to like you know
help him and it was just like that's
kind of sad
it's kind of sad so like
it just i don't know
i i really like
the awoken and the dreaming city and
beautiful
like my warlock is all like the season
lost stuff facts the trippy girl the uh
necro as i like to call it in the
necrotic drip yes as i call it something
grip nice now i'll show you my i will
trade notes after the show yeah you guys
got drip yeah i got homeless titan over
here so it's fine
and then my hunter is running the full
thorn armor with the new um
i've got a mark dangling on my hip in
case i run out of toilet paper
and then my titan is all like black
armory very like
deep stone crypt all of my characters
have a theme that's nice i want to say
with that i will say with regards to the
transmog can i just like lock my look
and that way if i switch pieces i don't
have to change the look can i just have
like a permanent look so when i'm
switching out gear for stats or
mods or whatever it is i don't i don't
like ghosts who switch and mods read a
lot sector and look i'm like why do i
look like i just fell through like 14
paint cans why do i look wrong i was
like i just had this set up like
no that was an annoying thing to me and
that's why i said i look homeless one
time because i was like oh i have like
because i like the new thorn armor or
the new marathon ornaments i've been
wearing those with like kind of the
quicksilver ornament
i was like cool got a theme great oh i
gotta switch over a couple things cause
i was gonna go do pvp let me switch them
why do i look like an idiot right now
i'd that literally happened just lock
lock them in that's all i wanted so yeah
i definitely am really really really
glad that dim now has the fashion option
for your loadouts
oh nice i've been doing that a lot yeah
they just added that like really really
recently
and i literally spent an hour just going
through all of my loadouts because i
like when i run close to the falling
star i have you know i have a look if
i'm running like
[Music]
how full is my vault oh let's look let's
open up dim right now
uh put me on the spot put me in the hot
speaker
what's the numbers i at about like
450 but that's because i haven't gone i
mean with the changes they announced
today i can go through and like delete a
good
ninety percent of my armor because the
armor now can get shrunk a lot that i'm
happy about yeah that was because a lot
of the reasons i kept it was for
like
outfits for like fashion
and then i have
just a lot of like oh this is really
good raid armor but now now that we can
change affinity
wherever for master worked armor
yeah
yep i can definitely shrink down my
vault
a lot well one more thing i went through
my vaults oh no go ahead no no i was
just gonna say one more thing before we
get to the twab stuff because i
wanted to ask you guys
from the trailer
what size of destination do you think
this is going to be
europa size or bigger
okay i think it's going to be maybe
nestle i think isn't nessus the biggest
destination necessary necessary
couple of the biggest
europa's got a lot up in the
got used for story and nobody goes there
anymore but
it actually was pretty big but yeah this
is massive
i think it's probably going to be
europa's
maybe necessitize because they've shown
like a lot of different place they have
like the more
white
bone looking like cathedral look you
have like the more jungly swamp look you
have like like there's a bunch of
different like biomes yeah so
i definitely think it's probably going
to be pretty big
which i'm excited for yeah because we've
seen i think this is the first time we
saw i don't know if it's going to be
considered like subterranean or just a
different part because you've got like
more floating platforms over kind of
like the lake of lava look off into like
the castle
which does not match like her main like
citadel area and then obviously the
whole swamp and depending on what
connections and stuff i'd like to see
because right now i'll say like there's
three
landing zones on europa i'd like to see
like
four to five
for that scale yeah i would be happy
with you know if it was five i'd be like
all right this is solid but
it just depends on the way they have it
set up the way we get to them because i
mean you've got three on europa about
that whole upper area if you go running
through it it takes a while to get
through but we never use it that much so
i'm hoping
same thing some of these places actually
get a little bit more use and with the
reusable campaign they probably will but
yeah i definitely hope so
but yeah
so
um
you gentlemen big small any planet
reference you want to kind of put it to
is it nessus edz i agree
i agree with with lady i think that um
that sounds about right like
right right at that size i
i think it'll be substantial but you
know
i write it right in that pocket i don't
see any
my main thing is i'm be honest let me
tell you what i care about
how many trans med zones
that's all i care about just don't do it
don't put one at the bottom and then
make me have to go through the whole
thing and then it's like can i get how
long did it take us to get the the trans
man at the top for europe
again
just give me some trans bad songs i'm
good i kind of hope it's not as big as
the other planets to be honest because
the thing about europa and nessus
less with nessus but definitely europa
is most of the space isn't used super
well and you're just flying through it
it takes a really long time
there's not really any reason for them
to be so big and i would rather them
create a small space that's super
intricate like
uh the taking kings uh like dreadnought
like dreadnought yeah
not with fire like the dreadnought i
think dreadnought's really great because
it was smaller yes you should have been
able to use your sparrow but it was
still small enough where you could run
across it and uh there were lots of
secrets and things to do and places to
explore and i think
because it's in a throne world you don't
even really have to make these places
connect in a way that makes sense it's
not like transmatting makes sense when
you're going to a thrones world right so
like you can go through portals that
lead to different areas and the
the world can be layered on top of each
other with different versions of it and
there's all these cool things that they
can do that i would be super
disappointed if it was literally just
like here's a swamp fly through
and and find you know the one castle
that you want to go to and then fly to
the one pyramid that has the the raid at
it and i just really hope they don't do
that i don't want to get on my sparrow
and fly through this place and begin to
resent the environment i would really
like it if it was smaller and more
focused and more yeah
kind of filled with secrets rather than
yeah that density
i got you yeah
yeah definitely now i get that i get
that
what else we gotta eat well to make
things of course spicy for a podcast
they felt dropping the first swab of the
year
and boy did it come out well and yet
it had to drop a turret at the end so
we're gonna hit the high notes first and
part of this discussion before i even
get into this because i've already put a
video out with the comments i've looked
at other videos seen their comments
we don't know all the information
which is the last thing we're going to
talk about
that's part of the problem of the way
this whole last one gets loaded out we
can still speculate about what the
issues are going to be and i'm still not
entirely sure they can solve them all
but when we get to the last section it's
all about communication we get some we
don't get it all some of it's going to
come later there's some secret it's just
weird so
you guys will understand when we get
there um we're gonna start one of the
most consistent there's only four main
things like the swab is pretty
straightforward they're like hey there's
a new trailer go watch it we're all
excited we are pumped out of our mind
they've been screaming bungee at the
rafters
so yeah
that being said artifact mod update
insert orb memes here
one of the consistent pieces of feedback
that we've been wanting to act on for a
while involves the unlocking of artifact
mods
we've all been asking for it starting in
season 16 players will no longer be
limited to the number of artifact mods
they can unlock this means that players
could feasibly unlock all 25 mods by the
end of the season
while we have made some small
adjustments to
the amount of xp required to unlock
artifact mods 1 through 12. in general
the pace of unlocking these first 12
should be close to what we've seen in
season 15's artifact for each unlock
after 12 increased xp will be required
to on for the next artifact mod to
unlock so the choice of which order to
unlock the mod still requires some
decision making if you want to go for
all of them you can so i wanted to get
you guys take on this one first thoughts
yays nays
any thoughts about it
yeah i think it's really great because
like for example this season especially
like the last column they're all kind of
good
because there's a build you can do with
i think it's thermoclastic something or
another i'm so smart
with the solar hammer where you can just
you can just throw away
yeah i'm seeing that yeah it's it's
stupid but it's it's fun but for me to
do that i'd have to
reset my artifact for the what third
time and i'm like oh boy there goes all
my glimmer which they so excited about
the cost
that's true yeah
you can still reset your artifact and
make your picks again and that will
still be there so
at what cost
i mean right now i'm sure the cost will
be the same but theoretically you have
to do for me i'm just going to say this
now i know everybody was excited about
this my one thing is why does that have
to be here's three quarters but we're
taking a quarter step back i like the
fact that we can unlock them but it's
like here's your normal one through 12.
but then it's gonna get longer and
longer and longer and if these seasons
are like normal seasons you might get
like
i don't know 14 15 something like that
trying to get all 25 is for the crazy
people who
are like
rank 1 000 this season i was walking
through the tower and i saw 1098 and i'm
going
what are you go outside
go outside
go touch garage yeah all of those things
are please go yeah anything go
something i know it's not the contest i
know it's not the best time to go
publicly into the world but at least go
like wave at the sun for a minute
not everybody does that even i'm like
season rank 3 30 which is the highest
i've ever been just because this
season's so damn long so it's like yeah
for me it's just the point to where
why does it have to be this exponential
curve at the end why can't it just be
linear they set the artifacts up to
where you can't really
you can't have two cool like mods on
your artifact like god forbid they ever
give us 14 energy so you can actually
have some crazy fun no here's ten you're
going to get this mod like one other
thing that's it
you can't ever double stack them they
already have it set up that way so why
not just let me linearly go like bam bam
bam bam bam bam bam have them all and
then we just have fun mix and match in
all season long why
that's my that's my one thing it's like
i'm happy i can unlock more and maybe
there's only a couple more i care about
but just the fact that like how long is
13 and 14 and 15 going to take
when they say it's like it's gonna be
increased i'm like is it like 100k 100k
100k million i'm gonna be like
so i just had to say it i'm like make it
linear that's just me it's gonna be a
lot i guarantee that's i know and if the
resets are still 10 grand and then they
go up somewhat like if it's 10 20 if
it's like 10 12 i don't even know how
much it is right now for the low ones
but
just
it's oh and we're gonna get some more of
these couple steps anyway i had to throw
that out there you guys seem mostly on
board this one isn't going to be the
point of contention anyway
uh when it comes to artifact mods
themselves we are bringing back a few
perennial favorites of anti-champion
mods anti-barrier scouts and bows
uh we've got some overload
auto rifles and smgs
there's a caveat to that because i'm
like dear god no
um which they have made more reliable
than previous seasons auto rifles and
smgs on overloads are like the worst if
there is another option in a season you
pick the other option
because it's always continuity
well yeah but it's always continuous
fire on something is what you need and
it's like continuous fire on an overload
champion when you have attrition on in
the middle of a master lost sector you
look at them like for half a second like
they ain't dead
so
yeah i'm hoping they fix overload
champions because those are a little
annoying uh and then they also mention
uh we'll also be highlighting the new
glaive archetype coming up in the witch
queen through a variety of artifact mods
including an option to make your glaive
the solution to unstoppable champions
and we have a few new artifact mods that
will enhance some of the new weapon
perks
interesting any thoughts on the upcoming
champions and now you at least know what
to grind for since i just put out a
video two days ago on what to grind for
and now it's updated yay
go get that go get that vontage channel
right now
yeah
i
prefer anti-barrier scouts
and bows over
auto rifles i mean now that we have
arbalest our list is pretty much
just never leaving that slot
yeah
very but like i don't know i think
definitely the fact that it's scout
rifles is really good because i just i
just like scout rifles scout rifles are
good
and
for me personally
i don't know i don't like auto rifles i
think auto rifles need a buff in pve yes
per se because they're they're like
you're shoot it's like you're you're
just like
barely doing anything
you're flicking them you're flicking the
guy and the guy's like i'm god
you can't touch me mm-hmm so yeah it's
just it's just uh
i'm
i both like and hate the champion system
me personally i think champions were
kind of you and me both
artificial
difficulty
band-aid and i think they've leaned on
it the same way
for way too long
i mean yeah we have scoring champions
but it's just like
you know you you there hasn't been a
whole lot of creativity in the champions
and that's like their
their answer of how do we make this
harder we'll throw some champions in
there and then make things one-shot you
yeah that's most of what we get right
now and the champions especially like in
some places where
you know overloads are
not always the most reliable
um anti-barriers if like if an
anti-barrier can move or teleport and
get out of the way and that shield pops
in the wrong place that's frustrating so
it's like
yeah it just yeah so i
it doesn't seem to be happening right
now for giant new champion questions but
yeah it's like
over it's like anti-barrier cool
overload well so we'll just have to see
i'm kind of like with you i'm like yeah
i have to see what's what on those
yeah i'm excited i've got a couple of
scouts i've been dying to use uh servant
leader and the kinetic it's been one i
want to dust off trusty and the energy
vision the confluence and the energy as
well so i i actually like from a
distance i could use my scalp on
annoying anti-various you know
antibiotic champion so yeah yeah i like
that i would evo i i hope they fix
the whole smg
you know auto rifle overload thing
because that's annoying those things be
dancing around and you shoot them and to
get the sustain stun sometimes it's just
so annoying especially when you're doing
a loss sector and stuff like that so
yours is one hit hand cannon says three
or two trigger pulls depending on if you
got the right perks on your weapon
so it really is just kind of
it's not they don't even play the same
way you're sitting there trying to
unload a whole clip just trying to get
something to remotely kind of stand
still and it never feels right the
others are just like pink
pink and you can control them so much
more easily with the other ones so yes i
do hope they make that
that fix
yeah
that's fine uh final positive point to
take a little bit of pressure off your
vault spade which is what we were
talking about earlier we're also making
some adjustments to the master work arm
the way masterwork armors work
starting with the launch of which queen
you can change the energy type so arc
solar void and now stasis which is just
another color
um a fully masterwork so you got to be
10 out of 10 energy unlocked uh you can
change the energy types you could go
from 10 out of 10 energy or 10 out of 10
arc to 10 out of 10 solar for a much
reduced cost a fully masterwork
piece of legendary gear can be changed
for the cost of ten thousand glimmer and
one upgrade module that's it
it's like beautiful
it's basically just like infusing a
piece of gear at this point that's good
while i fully master work exotic we'll
take twenty thousand glimmer and one
upgrade module
i
you and me both man bro i thought they
was gonna ask for a golf ball
or something
but that's kind of the thing it's like
if you make the investment in the golf
ball and then you find something with
slightly better stats you're like god
and now it's like you can make those
decisions but you can at least hey let
me repurpose this like there's more
flexibility in your builds move around
mods that type of thing is just going to
be better so it's like
see anybody see any major problems with
this one
no i love it topic is next i'll jump it
because um for me as a person
first of all they love to introduce new
armor
mods that's mods that are specific to
specific armor classifications any type
so it's like when they have a stasis
thing and i'm like damn i have no stasis
armor now i gotta
level this thing up put three you know
two or three golf balls or something and
it's like come on you know so give me
that flexibility and this is what we
were talking about e when we always do
the outriders comparison right we we say
look how easy it is to just switch this
and add this mod like that's what
destiny needs to stop discouraging me
from builds and armor and changing on
the fly that's why i'm so hard on them
with the artifact that's why i'm so hard
on them
from builds yeah like don't discourage
me i want to play in your sandbox i love
these options hey you got some stasis um
armor mods like i want to use those
don't make it difficult for me to say so
this is a great step i want to be
positive first i know we're going to go
in but this is a great positive step
salute to them on this one yeah
i i definitely agree i think
this was a
very
requested and much needed thing
so like for me i can now go through my
vault and like get rid of most of my
armor because i'd have like you know a
full like i'd have vog armor a specific
element i'd have arc arm i'd have like
deep stone crypt armor a specific
element because of the mods i mean like
the raid mods they're not like
it's not like garden of salvation where
you need to have the raid mods to do the
raid it's just like it's like icing on
the cake yes
they make it they make it a little bit
easier a little bit nicer but i
definitely think this is really nice
because especially with the
right now with at least with my team for
uh witch queen the raid we've been
already like thinking of like builds and
stuff like okay how are we going to do
this how are we going to do that okay
everyone should probably be running
protective light which with what we're
going to talk about next is going to be
really interesting
so should i just should i just get into
it just rip off the bend
band-aid rip is coming
comments are gonna be they're already
entertaining i've looked at my video and
there's bigger ones out there so
closing out
we are also making a change to the way
guardians create orbs of power with
weapons
in case you guys are audio listeners
lucy is giving that as a two giant
thumbs down
fyi
audio listeners she's definitely
of the new weapon crafting system will
encourage you to use many different
weapons and ask you to burn hard earned
masterwork materials on a weapon that
you may only be using for a few hours
just to generate orbs that seems like a
tall order like okay so they actually
realize that we're going to be using a
bunch of different weapons and we want
to masterwork them to play the way you
know make some orbs it's going to be a
little ridiculous so
this combined with our desire to act on
consistent player feedback that we want
um basically exotic weapons to be able
to generate orbs of power even though
they don't have a catalyst led us to
this implementation we'll be using in
which queen and beyond
it seems like a band-aid for a bullet
hole but we'll get there orb generation
sorry
funny it's one of those random metaphors
you hear from your parents and it
occasionally pops out
orb generation on weapon multi kills
will no longer be a function of a
weapon's masterwork status
if your vault of masterworked weapons if
if your vault is full of masterwork
weapons that doesn't matter now
[Laughter]
trust me i know uh but will instead be
provided by a suite of armor mods which
are unlocked automatically for all
players which plug into the helmet armor
mod socket
each
such mod will apply the orb generation
effect to all weapons you have equipped
of a particular damage type
so a single mod will cover multiple
weapons in your arsenal if and only if
they share a damage type this also
applies to weapons that change damage
types like hard light kinetic and
osmosis we will continue to create
exotic catalysts over the next few
seasons but in the meantime
we will be able to generate orbs with
cloud strike thorn thunderlord terriba
and any other weapon in the game
who wants to go first
i'll go first hey there we go guest is
gonna take it because i should not i'll
i'll take i'll take it first i guess um
bungie what the [ __ ] are you thinking
what the hell
i'm sorry like this is probably one of
the dumbest things i have ever heard in
i think what there's 24 exotics without
catalysts i think like a very small
number of exotics that don't have
catalysts
and they're going to basically remove
the whole
i would say at least for pve which is
what
i would say um
most people play pv pve stuff at one
point or another like that's why i
master work weapons is to make orbs i
don't really care about whatever the
masterwork is i mean like if it's
something that i need i'm like oh that's
cool otherwise i'm like
about it
like because when you're doing grand
masses when you're doing master raids
what you normally run is you run
protective light
and you run the
picking up orbs charges you with light
talk like that is a
like
because like
it just
it just really frustrates me because you
know they made they we went two steps
forward with you know the artifact thing
the the champion mods the armor master
you know we read all this cool stuff and
they're like oh by the way all of the
stuff you've mastered worked is
literally pointless now
i think this is almost as bad as sun
setting
like this is bad i think i think it's
really bad because
like
in end game content now the only way
you're gonna and even
even if you think about like most end
game content has match game
most people don't run all the same
element as
like for me i run my subclass as like
void and then i run like an arc heavy on
the solar
secondary right with the next matching
of the elements right yeah so then i
have everything covered it's like that
that makes sense and now bungie is
punishing players for doing that and
that's
not fair and then on top of that your
helmet mod helmet
mods are already full anyways because
you have you know
any minor or major one which can be
anywhere from one to five if you're
doing intellect and then on top of that
there's your ammo finder mods which for
end game content you kind of need that
like if you don't have your heavy if you
don't have
your special weapons you're not going to
be doing as much damage and
damage is kind of really important
especially in rates and grand masters
so like having to choose between orb
generation and whether i get ammo
is really stupid
and i feel like this is a
charged with life or charged with light
nerf disguised as a quality of life
change
that's how i feel let's let's get trav
he seems to have the disagreeing father
look so i want to know where travis is
going with this travels like i'm totally
good uh set twitter on fire again go
yeah i wanna hear this
as usual have a moderate opinion which
usually i get in trouble not for having
extreme opinions i get in trouble for
having moderate opinions around people
who are all fanatics
so here we go
i think people are overreacting to this
majorly
uh for for a whole bunch of reasons um
i think that we one we haven't seen it
in action yet we don't know what the
mods actually do it could be that they
give us
bigger orbs remember remember when they
used to give us big orbs for stuff and
then they realized we were getting our
supers too fast so they made these like
one sixth
you know the difference between you know
the difference between an or view
generated by your super and when you
generated
generated from a masterwork so it could
be that they're going back to the to the
old orbs with this new mod which would
definitely offset kind of the
inconvenience the other thing is that
bungie has said multiple times that
they're that they think we get our
powers too quickly including our supers
and so this could be just part of that
effort to generally kind of tune that
down and if that's best for the sandbox
it's best for the sandbox man i i
personally think that that we we
probably get our our super too quickly
granted i've been playing a lot of dares
of eternity so that's like oh my god i
just always have my super you just
unload your rocket launcher for about
five minutes in there that's all yeah
unload unload your archives for five
minutes and then use your super and then
repeat
and dares um but that as well um i also
think that um
the way that that the current system was
set up for getting orbs was kind of bad
like i i get i get that we had to master
work all of our weapons but
to their point it wasn't ubiquitous it
wasn't it wasn't universally applied to
all weapons it was some weapons and then
some exotics you applied by doing the
catalyst and if you're a new light
player that's incredibly confusing and
it it also is kind of a weird way to do
it it's like this this master working of
weapons had no purpose except to do this
one thing
and now we get a chance to see okay well
are they going to give us a reason to
master work our weapons then if they're
taking this away what does that look
like i don't i don't think we know the
answer yet but i i'm pretty sure the
answer isn't we're going to master work
weapons so that you can see how many
things you killed with it i think maybe
we can agree that that's not happening
right
they i think they're probably going to
add something that gives you a reason to
master work weapons but we'll see
that and the final point is when people
say oh all of my work is ruined all
these weapons i masterwork it's like
bro was it really that hard to
masterwork your weapon
those shards are so damn good
i i don't even farm for those shards and
i've got like hundreds of them and like
master working weapons does not take a
lot of effort or resources if you were
talking about your armor i'd be with you
i'd be like oh yeah that sucks your
armor you put like a lot of time in a
master working that but your weapons i
mean it didn't really take you that long
let's be honest let's not be prima
donnas about this you know
it doesn't take a ton of effort to
master weapons so
i think i think players should probably
wait and see before they freak out i
don't think we understand the system
well enough yet um i will say this
if i'm gonna have to go into my armor
and change the mods out more often to
match whatever weapon type i'm using i
think that generally is a bad gameplay
thing and i say it the same thing to
people who go oh bring back ammo sense
it's like yeah you know what i want in
the middle of gameplay i want to open up
my menu that'd be like if i was playing
on a pc and in order to use an item on
my pc game i had to like quit to desktop
and then go back into the game you know
what i mean like it's like not good game
design so i think if there's anything to
be
upset about it's to be upset about how
often bungie is expecting us to go into
our menus during combat i feel like you
should be going into your menus really
only during uh during loading screens
unless there's a special circumstance
like you're setting up for a raid
encounter or something i think that is
really like the big thing that bothers
me is how often they're they're
expecting me to go and you know how long
it takes to load your armor and then to
load your mods and then wait for those
to load and then you have to wait for it
to apply and all that stuff i think that
could potentially be the worst thing
about this but um i don't know yeah
let's see let's see let's wait and see
that's my opinion on this i think people
are flipping out a little too soon i
think you're
you're right because bungie or some of
the community managers did say that we
don't have all of the puzzle pieces
which
frustrates me that they would only give
us one puzzle piece another picture yeah
that's that's my biggest that's my
biggest issue is they said oh don't
worry this will make sense later and
we're like is it gonna be
this better be i won't say that this
better be worth it but like
i just worry
a lot because
not like you're like you're right travis
i it's not that hard to master work a
gun you just push button push button
push button done oh it has a gold border
now whoop you do like
the only reason
for me personally that i master weapons
is to get those orbs of light so that i
can then become charged with light so
that i can have protective light so then
i don't die
that's it that's all that's all i what's
all i really want and now
i feel like that has been like i guess
the meta in like grand masters and
everything else so maybe that this is
i'm trying to change that i like i said
we don't have the full picture we have
like
a like a corner piece of a puzzle and
they're like don't worry we'll give you
the next puzzle piece next week
i think it is a communication problem
more than it is like a game design
problem like but here's the thing if if
if this change is annoying at all
as a gameplay thing i will be in your
guys's court like i'll be the first guy
to be like i you guys know me i complain
about everything like if i if if this is
an annoying gameplay mechanic if it's
bad game design i'm going to be the
first guy like storm in the gates to be
like this is bad but i just don't think
we know enough yeah and i don't think i
don't think yeah existing i think saying
the existing system was a good way to
set it up is like
really do you think it was good like
come on it wasn't good yeah i think a
good i guess middle ground solution
since a lot of people are
i guess annoyed that it's going to be
affinity based so like if you're wearing
a solar helmet you have to like it has
to like everything has to match like
solar to sub class to everything has to
match and for some people that's not
like their play style like people don't
like
that's what worries me is bungie is like
saying hey
you have to play our way right you have
to play it this way like that's not like
not everybody does that
i think a good way
to
alleviate
uh
this problem
is
instead of making it like a helmet mod
because how like he's like like we've
said armor
armor mods are already cramped i mean on
gauntlets we have champion mods we have
this and that and this like all these
mods
that are like crowding our helmets the
only thing i can really think of to
maybe
alleviate that is
either a have it be a fifth mod slot but
then
when you think of like raid
stuff
raids already have that fifth mod slot
so then it's like
i don't know another suggestion i've
seen people say is make it a ghost mod
instead of
an armor mod because
let's face it the only thing we really
put on our ghostbusters
is the xp boost and once you're 100 or
whatever artifact level you need to be
you don't really need the xp boost
anymore
like i sometimes when i'm grinding gms i
sometimes have the vanguard
like extra legendary drops but that's
like
if it's something that i'm like wanting
oh i need a better palindrome or i need
a better
whatever
like
i think a ghost mod is a nice middle
ground where it's still a mod but have
it be
just that's a great idea i love that
have it be weapons that you have
equipped generators doesn't matter if
it's exotic does it matter if it's
legendary does it matter if it's yeah so
that's
not matching yourself intrinsic yeah i
like that a lot yeah
maybe have maybe you have to like
i guess
having it be an intrinsic thing if you
master work your ghost but then it's
kind of the same problem as they had
before where you're masterworking your
weapons
just
to generate orbs so i don't know
i feel i'm not
no no sorry go ahead i don't know
i don't know i'm just
because we don't have all of the puzzle
pieces i'm
i guess
because we don't have all of the puzzle
pieces we don't really know what it's
going to be like
all of the community men are saying
don't worry it's going to be good
okay yeah but i can only take their
trust so far
right
could you give us some evidence but the
thing about the destiny community is
that they take everything at bungie's
word except for when they decide not to
right so like bungie right now is
telling you that the witchcrane is going
to be dope and i feel like everyone
who's a destiny stan agrees with them
and it's just
i feel like we react to things at the
wrong time and when you do that you get
you get half-assed attempts i feel like
another but if they do half-assed
communication they do kind of bring it
on themselves sometimes
they also they also do bad
implementations and i'm not saying that
any of this is the player's fault i'm
just saying that sometimes you be you
become your own worst enemy
i feel like
we reacted to sun setting at the wrong
time right they said we're going to
sensate weapons and then they did a
really bad implementation and then
before we even gave them a chance to
kind of fix that they reverse their
decision and i feel like that's gonna
have long-term negative effects because
of power creep and they're eventually
gonna have to sunset like we've talked
about these problems a lot yeah i just i
just think that there's a there's a lot
of times where the destiny community
probably should just like hold their
horses and i know that's an impossible
idea in the age of the internet where
nobody holds their horses ever and it's
it's this game of like hey but i but i
would i would i would encourage player
people listening to the show at least to
just give them a chance you're giving
them a chance with a witch queen you're
giving them a chance with void 3.0 why
wouldn't you give them a chance with
changing something that wasn't that good
to begin with like okay so but here's
the thing
do you want to go cog because i'm going
to go when i go so you go first yeah let
me let me go i've been waiting
um yeah i i think the problem here is
the the
when you're not fully transparent and
your information is then tied to your
next marketing rollout you're gonna get
the smoke because the problem is people
don't know the full
picture and that's what they want right
they want the full picture so it's like
hey it's gonna be cool right that that
sounds great but right now the
information that you're given is
incomplete and it doesn't sound great
and to the point you know that lucy was
saying it says that
here's my point
as of right now then what is the purpose
of master working a weapon then
like what what is the purpose what are
we doing it for because if this new mod
is going to do this and give orbs is it
just going to say that i killed 672
fallen that's why i'm master working so
again they may have this most amazing
idea for weapons right
but when you give incomplete information
you give up you put us in us to
speculate and now tear this apart and um
yeah the other the other point i would
just say is uh like we talked about with
the helmet mods and stuff like there's
already limited space as it is with the
four slots i mean me i'm a person i use
the uh you know the the ammo finder
there's some really cool ones you know
like you know dynamo and you know if you
punch you get more super energy you're
already now
really packing a lot in those helmet
slots as it is right so is the solution
hey we're gonna get another slot you
know say per armor like i know e that's
one of your things that you've been
talking about as far as trying to gain
more stuff so this is one of those
situations where i'm with travis in the
sense that i am not i do feel there's an
overreaction i would drive in that sense
i do think people are going a little too
crazy until the information comes out
but i'm with e in the sense that they do
this to themselves because you can't
give incomplete information what you
think's gonna happen and i think that
the problem they have is they like yo
they're gonna love this when we tell
them like i think they're generally
excited i honestly i think they like
y'all i'm sure i know who they are
yeah they go like they're gonna be so
hyped when we tell them that they can
get the orbs that they want and you're
forgetting it's incomplete because
what's gonna happen is this
we're gonna get that witch queen trailer
we're gonna get those bullet points
we're gonna get what the actual goal is
right and then we go like oh okay fine
right but we can't see that now so again
it's there it's their issue so that's
all i got really
i know you about to go in
but that's my main thing with this thing
is just
just got to be better man don't this is
when you when you tie too much stuff to
the hype train
this is where now can get you in trouble
but that's all i got
yeah e
oh so no
yup it's coming
so i mean for me it's a magnitude of
things one is
um lucy mentioned already charged with
light mods
this does feel like a
shadowed nerf to those as your
very consistent way to get mods is now
going to be restricted in some fashion
right now you can hey you got
enhancement cores you do in-game stuff
okay
all your weapons are masterworked you
get a group kill cool
that's just making some orbs it's a
consistent thing you can write a lie on
it as travis was saying well hey let me
go into this last sector today okay i
logged in today did a little lost sector
granted let me go tomorrow oh this is
completely different types of uh orbs
and shields that hold on let me go into
here let me switch around
i gotta get different weapons to make
sure they go with the mods okay now i'm
good and you have to do that every time
you go into a lost sector so now you're
switching the mods a lot more
also ammo finder they've already nerfed
that once because the ammo finder is now
based off of the number of kills you get
people have done testing on this thing
it's not just like hey you might see
these more often it's now like you need
x number of kills to actually get a
brick
like that's a thing that's already been
done ammo is a unreliable thing
to an extent right now which is somewhat
frustrating you're like i can go through
a lost circle and be like dude i am
swimming in heavy ammo i can like fire
my heavy weapon the entire time i go
through and the other time it's like i
have five bullets and i can't find one
in my name it the unreliable nature and
rng of ammo should not be part of your
skill it should not be of like hey i had
a really good one why well everybody had
plenty of heavy ammo we had a really
crappy one why
nobody could find heavy and god don't
get me started about attrition that's
just annoying so i i i was like
i know but yeah but the the thing about
orbs is they're not necessary to
complete the game like if even if this
system is terrible the change the
changes is is bad all you're losing are
small orbs that kind of have a very
minimal impact on the game to begin with
you know what i'm saying it's not super
generation is important though super
generally it's important you have
generating supers you have charged with
time
it's not like you're going into the
encounter with with with no bullets if
you don't have this modicum of course of
course the way like way more irritating
than this are the mods for fighting
champions because those are necessary to
complete the encounter and it requires
you to go into your inventory every
encounter and kind of figure out which
ones you're going to need and then
communicate with other people to figure
out which ones they're going to have i
view that as way more annoying and kind
of interrupting to gameplay then oh i
didn't equip the right mod i guess i'm
not going to get orbs one player one
thing i do think you're minimizing the
importance of protecting light and end
game builds like those are extremely key
if you're gonna do high-end content you
wanna for survivability protective light
is crazy then there's a lot of charge
with light builds and other builds that
people really use and you're taking up
slots that i mean it i can't minimize
the the customization of of some of
these things that they themselves put in
these slots for us to use
well it's also the fact that i can't
take it the orbs
but they're not game breaking is my but
it's also you get to the limitation of
like you take a system you have right
now every single weapon can be
masterworked
theoretically unless they're gonna
rework armor completely so if you want
to set that aside and we have like two
new whole mod
sockets that's a different discussion
because then we're getting new armor and
changes the way you play
if things stay the way they are right
now you have your stat mod
you have your combat mod
and then you have your two helmet mods
if they are helmet mods
and say you go into something with two
different types of shields
that's your helmet mods you don't have
ammo finders you don't have ashes to
assets you don't have dexterity if it's
dexterity i'm trying to remember no it's
targeting which is even more pvp related
targeting targeted
yeah so it's like depending on if you
are so
it's a subtle way for bungie who's
trying to push us away from
abilities again but now more in a pve
sake
to try and push this away from again you
said the charge with light buds
and these things it's like i know
charged with light is not a required
thing people can do it with they can't
do it without in-game content light
master when they already lean heavily
into the artificial difficulty which i
hate that term but it's the best way i
can say it but things do get really
like you can die really easily and
protective light is like one thing they
have put into the game to mitigate that
if you build into it it is one of the
few things that will help with that
what's up
and then also let's be honest you know a
lot of us run
like a great special weapon or great
energy weapon for example you run into
shotgun sometimes i know i run like a
shotgun finder and a linear fusion right
like sometimes i'll double up on it
right yeah and the last one i want to
say that lucy made is a good point is
the scent that says that
not everybody's running around with all
void weapons
to generate the orbs like like so now
you're forcing me to not have player
choice and play the way i want to play
with the exotics and the energy and the
type of guns i want to play because if i
don't have this mod that makes
masterwork for only arc weapons you know
what i'm saying i can't use gal horn now
it's the guy well you know you know what
i'm not that i can't but i can't use uh
exotics that don't have that are not
masterwork that don't generate orbs that
relate to that element type and i think
that's
deficiency you know what i mean so
absolutely kind of assuming a lot about
how it's going to work and i i just
think but they no but they but they
literally did say
it's going to be tied to an element that
part they gave us right didn't you give
us how big the orb is going to be if the
orb is big enough to wake up from the
fact that two of your weapons aren't
generating orbs for trade right
necessarily because if i want to use
another if i'm doing a nightfall and
there's different energy types right
who's to say like that's what i'm trying
to say i mean this is i agree with you
trav that
we don't know because they didn't
complete the sentence right we don't we
don't know i give you that we we don't
it's just that
what we do know just sounds
very restrictive and they need to
complete this picture otherwise people
like myself you know we're going to
speculate and go hey what's going on
here that's i i just i just worry when i
hear stuff that restricts
build diversity right and kind of like
forces you into a thing but again in
your point they need to tell us the rest
they do well i mean the other piece is
now you picture you've arc solar void
you have different archetypes
kinetic's another one
right oh no i forgot about that i was
like i don't know how many people have
forgot or not about that one
you have an entire slot
that if you want to use a primary
typically weapon one of those two is
almost always going to be kinetic
and if you want to make mods for kinetic
that one just now lives there
then you have uh then you have two other
weapons and unless you're running a
specific loadout that matches everything
and they love putting match game on
every difficult piece of content like
every piece of content has match game on
it
you just made a limitation for somebody
to try and solo a piece of content
a little just like that much harder or
that much more annoying because now
depending and say yeah you have arc
solar oh it's stasis and kinetic you
have five different ones
you can't fit them all depending on what
you're doing on there is one lost sector
that does have all three shields
you have a kinetic weapon and you have
two shields and then you have that one
like you can't the bit the one of the
things i'm trying to get at is the fact
that we have a system now
and i'll get to kind of my point in this
long-winded discussion that like you
have people that have like whether they
have 30 or 530 things that they're
holding on to because i've seen 35
things in a vault and i'm like i don't
even understand how it's that small
tassie did a thing about that and i'm
like y'all are insane
there's people like me wait
there's people like me who have way too
damn much and i'll feel like i'm working
on cleaning the armor thing will help
but
clean it
i get it
but it's like
the master working is one of those
things like that's the e the enhancement
cores are not too hard to get i part of
me worries that they're leaning so hard
into helping casuals who are like oh i
can't really get these masterworks like
i can't master work the weapons because
i don't know where to find cores well i
just put this mud and now i can make
orbs like everybody else
is this a thing to make it easier for
the person who hasn't farmed those
materials just to say well what are
these orbs of light well now just put a
mod in here and i can make some orbs at
least
so i worry that it's that way as opposed
to
i mean if you have like a hundred master
weapons now you're just like what'd they
do i think a little baby step bump
i i guess the question for ue that uh i
think maybe trying to travis is alluding
to
is
what i know we don't know but we're
going let's play a game let's guess
what would ease your mind as a trade-off
that they could do
to make a change like this worth it for
you
oh
[Music]
i mean
i know we talked about the bigger or i'm
sorry we talked about the bigger or
potential thing but what other what else
could they do that you'd be like you're
all right you know what
that's good i could deal with this
i mean that's the big question
and that's the hard part is like we got
half of the you know here's the white
paper
but i got page one through six and i
need i need seven through twelve i need
the other pages of the document just so
i have all the information
and to me
like even datto said it was like i
listened to his because i was curious
you went three for three
why did you have to drop this right now
that's probably the other piece that
annoys me more is like they could have
the perfect solution they don't want to
spoil until everybody logs in on which
queen they like science and surprise us
then i would almost rather have it there
because he was so excited to tell you
about how you're going to be able to get
us but you're not mass to work
nobody it's like it's six weapons and
you're at that point i don't even
i could care less about the six exams i
heard i saw so many people tweeting
about this and commenting about it oh
why can't why can't we generate orbs
with those exotics true no he's right
travis right
they have gotten a lot of catalysts out
there and if you're like hey we did six
more catalysts this is done like there's
not that many left is the point like
doing this now
there's not that many left that need it
that's kind of the idea it's like it's a
small fix
for that and as lucy said it's masked in
some other way it's like but so i can
speculate all day couldn't it be a big
fix for the game in general like was
this system good do people stand by that
this was a good system for masterwork
weapons because i would argue what's
wrong with just making
i was like like so there's a there's a
like an idea that i saw what if master
working weapons increases the stats in
some way like you do with armor what if
it already does that what if it did it
more what if it added a mod slot what if
it you know what i mean like there
there's so many opportunities for them
to expand weapons
you give me extra miles
that's one of the things some people
said like we have technical limitations
on weapons this is one of the things
like
they have technical limitations on
weapons and how many perks can be active
on a weapon at a certain time the way
their code is built stuff will break and
if this is a point where taking this off
of the weapon functionality and moving
into armor giving us more flexibility
that could be a good thing i'm not
saying that that's not a bad thing at
all that's a thing like but again it's
like
you make what potentially has where we
have some cooler weapons and crafting
may be a thing but on the other side we
do have
they're like hey look into builds and
builds and stuff like that but here's
like we're just going to shove more and
more into these same slots
and it's like okay now it's like oh you
want to do orbs well these two mod slots
are going to be taken okay you want to
do champions these two mod slots are
taken do you want to do any artifact
mods well this only one artifact mod
will fit in a class item because we make
them so big you can't do too much like
they already tell you you are very
limited in what options you do have so
you're like you see people like fallout
cool guy and other people like let me
make a build and it's like so niche
like it takes some of those like if you
don't watch a youtube channel it's like
good luck finding that it's not like hey
i can experiment freely here i've got
all this energy and mods to work with
it's like here here here here here it's
like okay you can mess with like these
two spots it's how it feels sometimes so
it is just one of those things when
it says like hey we're going to take
helmet mods now which you use for
certain purposes and we're going to make
you make another decision to limit how
much more benefit you have it's like
it's a functionality that was in the
game now you're going to be potentially
limited on the functionality guns may
get cool weapon crafting may be
fantastic and i don't know the rest but
it is just like it's this weird moment
of like that's was like i don't know the
answer and i don't know what's gonna
make it better but i also know like
we've had weird systems get launched
like transmog that didn't come out well
weapon crafting i have my hunches i
don't know how it's gonna launch if
weapon crafting doesn't come out well
this is gonna be that much worse that's
an issue so like 100 and i and i think
we should just wait until weapon
crafting is out like this isn't a change
that's happening right now right so i i
just think
like the bungie in my mind is trying to
fix the weapon problem which is that
weapons have never really felt unique or
fun to upgrade or anything like that
they have this crafting system coming up
they're clearly changing something about
masterwork and we don't know what that's
going to look like yet and i i think
that people are kind of relating this
problem to the armor problem which as
you know e we've talked about this on
the show a million times that armor
isn't really in a good spot to begin
with for a whole bunch of reasons and
yes
putting more stuff into it is obviously
going to make it worse but one problem
at a time right they're trying to fix
weapons this season clearly they're
trying to fix void next season they're
going to fix ark you know what i mean
like i think armor has to be adjusted in
some way uh and i i think the current
system of doing championship mods and
the whole way that the mods with the
artifact work is terrible like all that
stuff i have problems with but wouldn't
it be nice if master working weapons
felt good
and if
but look i don't i don't have confidence
in it either i i think that they'll
probably mess this up it's punching but
i would love i'm gonna give them the
benefit of the doubt until i play it and
i just think i'll fail you if you're
unhappy like me look at champ sounded
like me this is why we have three people
on the show because somebody's batting
on the other side of the batter's box
over there i just get to hear travis be
the voice of reason this is awesome
continue
i an ease the one steaming this is great
i'm sorry this is awesome moment hey i
gotta pick my moments to be this guy i
don't get them all that often right i'm
gonna be crazy once in a while
yeah i gotta be the crazy one every blue
moon it just doesn't happen often so
i wanted to actually ask lucy after all
of our ranting
back to you
uh where like
what as travis did ask is like
what do you think would make this
beneficial what do you think we don't
know that would
potentially be
worth it
i mean if
i don't know man like too much pressure
sorry
no no it's fine it's fine i'm just like
thinking cause
well yes
i think the current artifact system with
having to put champion mods on our armor
is dumb picking up a little picking up a
little tension there
but i also think that putting them like
on the weapons is also dumb because then
that limits exotics that can't be
champion mods so like i guess in a
perfect world
it would just be intrinsic for like the
champion mods for example like
anti-barrier scout
you you will knock that in the artifact
and then anytime you have a scout rifle
equipped congratulations it's andy
barrier it doesn't matter if it's exotic
doesn't matter then you're not wasting
any mod slots because like right now
there's a lot of builds that i use that
i use those
those um
like affinity mods like the arc mods the
void mods the stasis mods on your
gauntlets yeah but if you're running
champion end game content nope i can't i
can't do that i have to
that's why i've been really like oh wow
these the artifacts the artifact
artifice armor from grasp of avarice
the only thing you need it for is
gauntlets you don't need it for helmets
you don't need it for change it doesn't
do much
it doesn't i mean maybe class item and
maybe gauntlets but that's really it
that's really there's one i actually
looked because now that you say that
sorry to interrupt but like i looked i
was like
why do i have an artifice helm what the
hell and i looked and it's like ash's
assets is slightly cheaper that's it
like or something like that it's like
there's one mod that like is a little
cheaper that could go there but i'm like
most of them like go in two slots
it's class and arms yeah
yeah so like
i guess
if but if this is like
if bungie could figure out a way to like
alleviate the mods that we have like are
like required to run to
play their game yeah another way i could
think
that this would be fine
is if they completely deprecate ammo
finder mods
completely get rid of all of them
and just make it that'd be great
if they got rid of those mods and just
not have it be rng randomness to get
weapons like intrinsically in a weapon
if you
if it's just when you have a weapon
equipped you're gonna find ammo for it
i think that would be fine if they got
because the problem is is with helmet
mods
there's a lot that is crammed in there
so if they got rid of
if they got if they just completely
deprecated got rid of
the
ammo finder mods on your helmet
then i would be
a lot
better
because then i could run kinetic
and then i could run whatever my
secondary is like void or arc or
whatever and then i wouldn't really have
to worry about
oh god i'm running a rocket launcher i
need my rocket launcher ammo finders
because
you would just have it equipped it would
just be like oh you have rocket launcher
ammo equip rocket launcher crypt okay
that means ammo you're gonna find ammo
like i really don't like that ammo is
rng yeah i think that's kind of dumb and
that's it's not
it's not the player's fault
it's
like like when you're doing master vog
and you're at atheon and
you go to
you go to dps and like i don't have
heavy but my friend is like oh i have
like 15 bricks on the ground
and i'm like not doing as good dps yeah
because of
something that is crazy
out of my control yeah it's just i've
always wondered why um
why the armor mod system doesn't exist
on weapons
like why why isn't it when you level
they're already technically limited on
weapons as it is i mean they've said
like if too many perks are active on a
weapon
if we add anything no if we add anything
else it's gonna they've said it's like
something's gonna stop working
but they're all they're always
optimizing their system they're adding a
weapon crafting system maybe maybe
they're gonna offload some of that ammo
finder and some of the stuff that's
related to specific weapons like if you
have a scout rifle it does armor or
barrier piercing that stuff maybe those
mods will be moving to
weapons or you'll have an option to do
it on either right you can do it on your
armor if you have room there or you can
put it on weapons i just i kind of see
this big problem with
this complete lack of parody when it
comes to masterworking armor versus
weapons and i i'm hoping when i first
learned about master working
when i learned about weapon crafting my
first thought was oh they must be fixing
it so that master working weapon isn't
just you get orbs you know what i mean
and i'm hoping that that's where they're
going with this and i i think the reason
they're not telling us is because they
want to keep weapon crafting a secret
secret why wouldn't you if it's
something that big and players find out
that that's what weapon crafting is that
you can you now have 10 power on each of
your weapons like people would lose
their minds so i'm waiting
and if that yeah that's the first guy to
write the six out of ten review but no
no no no no
are an annoying thing in the menu but
the fact that like there are moments
when i'm like i could kill for just ammo
sense for this moment when it's just
like crappy rng it's like that's
shouldn't happen it's like the ammo as
you as we've all said like ammo
shouldn't be a test of a player skill
like random rng that type of stuff
shouldn't be it's like i can get sniped
and it's like yeah i was out of position
if i can't do dps because i don't have
ammo dropping in the ground or i go into
the you know in vault of glass i need to
shoot oracles they don't have sniper
ammo dropping anywhere it's a different
issue that's all what were you gonna say
i say the same about orbs
if you're nothing without your orbs then
you don't deserve to have that maybe you
shouldn't
here with the oh jesus oh no
oh no
i'm sorry
i mean what's nice about
this
charged with i guess orb generation
because
at least with endgame content orb
generation with your weapons was the
most consistent way to get charged with
light and
using protective light with charged with
light is
the meta i guess or becoming charged
with light to then have that like
pocket resist
in your that resist in your pocket
basically so like whenever you're like
in the red that resist kicks in and you
can like live a little bit longer or
use this resist to like slide into cover
and not die
which in raids that's
important i think anyways so i think
this change allows people to not be so
clutching their masterwork weapons so
hard they can experiment with other
things like literally today as soon as
the 12 dropped and my raid group read it
we already swapped to running elemental
wells
i mean what's really funny is before
before that we already were like
thinking about elemental wells but then
we're like okay if there's parts where
we're all separated
and the people who aren't generating the
wells
like a first step like for example a
good example is like
the um
second encounter in garden of salvation
where you're basically just
doing like a relay race where basically
you you're by yourself killing ads and
then someone comes and helps you and
then you're by yourself if
basically
i think
well yes it is
bad
that
we're losing
orb generation on masterwork weapons a
lot of people in pve
only master work weapons to get for that
orb generation
i hope
that master working
weapons
will be more
important will make you be able to
please tell me why maybe you
like
that's my biggest problem right now is
they haven't told us okay you get to
master like what's the point of master
working something for pve now like
there's no point yeah i won't say
there's no point but we don't know very
much
with the information provided currently
i mean yeah i would say master working
in pvp without orbs
will not make a difference because a
little bit of range a little bit of
stability in pve
not going to make enough of a difference
that it's worth any material
so yeah they need to prove to us now
why does master work valid
like how is this going to work when we
have five different m like damage types
and then god forbid in lightfall when we
get six and we have a green subclass and
we have more
chaos in like the armor subclasses like
i'm this i'm i'm hoping this is one of
those things i'm hoping they've thought
it through
but we had new lights trip into dares of
eternity
are you implying
your lack of confidence
sometimes sometimes i mean big systems
are generally looked at
transmog was a big cell we're like this
is gonna be terrible
i don't just i just don't transmog that
much because it's annoying that's all so
it's like it's just a cool system they
were happy about and i don't do it
because i'm like i'll go pick up a
bounty fine go do some stuff but it's
like it took him a while just to step
that one back so it's like i don't want
weapon crafting to come out and be like
okay we really wish it would work with
this this this way okay well in season
17 we'll give you this one season 18
we'll give you this one season 19 we'll
give you this one and finally weapon
crafting works well in
lightfall
that's such a pessimist
you sound like trav now what's going on
playing too much iron banner that's what
i'm saying i blame blame it all on that
yeah i don't know i'm
until we get more information yeah i'm
like that's really like with them
deprecating ammo finder mods that's
really the only thing i can think of
because they they've got to know their
helmets are already crowded yeah they've
gotten like come on
yeah they got it down but she's not that
dumb right
right they're smart people it's just
some sometimes things don't make it into
you know the content we're hoping it's
with that's why
apparently now the weapon crafting twab
whichever you know whatever week that
falls on is going to be like
picking through that thing with a
fine-tooth comb that's i was like i
gotta know more about waffling crafting
that's the big thing it's like
and but as she's saying like if ammo is
this would be a nice time for them to do
a nice little oh by the way remember
when like hey those ammo finder mods you
worried about don't really need them so
much anymore yeah like that would be
like okay here's the step coming back
the other direction those are the that's
the nice things i hope to read on the
weapon crafting candidates i think so
i just because like they said oh we're
doing this but they don't they didn't
release i mean they said why like oh to
give
non-masterworked exotics
the ability to generate orbs i'm like
that's cool and all
but like and you said oh
this will help with like then later they
said like
they talked about how oh you guys just
don't have the full picture well can you
at least give us a hint or something
yeah
because they're just like oh it'll all
make sense like uh or isn't he bountiful
he's like don't
no okay so i said it last time i don't
want to know if zavala or
ikora or aris die in the first mission
that story but if you're going to be
like hey we're going to change up the
way the functionality of your armor and
your weapons work
to it i don't want weapon crafting to be
surprised to you you don't want to show
up to weapon crafting and they're like
hey surprise ebontis you take any weapon
out of your vault you put it into this
machine and it turns it into the armor
2.0 where you can equip you know 10
power worth of mods you don't want that
day to be to like blow your mind you
want to know all that going in
system-wise i mean i would like to know
more than we have now i think that's the
content creator and you speaking and not
the fair destiny personally oh
damn
no i don't want to know story spoilers a
story is like we're in this japanese to
understand java javascript
that's the glare that's what i'm going
to call the glaive is the javathune
good recovery right no um
like the story with sabbath is very cool
anything that happens to rely on that
don't tell me anything that i don't want
to know but like give me that sandbox
but yeah it's like understanding
the way like at least some idea of how
weapon craft is weapon crafting going to
be expensive are my 18 000 weapon parts
should they be in the trash like just
just some of that stuff i do want i want
the system stuff
yeah yeah crafting that's what we need
like at least some
expectations because remember when they
told us like hey this is not going to go
over too well and then we're like hey it
didn't go over too well
if we have some of those moments and we
get this that this wasn't built well and
we're stuck with it now like oh like
that's kind of one of those tough ones
the fact that they had self-awareness
they didn't think it was going to be
something that you all jumped out at
doesn't that make you think that maybe
they're doing it for the betterment of
the game design and and we should wait
like at least away yes
we've said we'll wait for the stuff but
that just finally like takes us back to
the communication part and it's just
like right
which is why you don't tie things to
marketing that's what this is well no
but that's the other thing if you're
gonna say don't spoil anything why'd you
tell me this one
because yeah that's a mistake
i think players get more excited about
the stuff that isn't story when it comes
to destiny and i think if you find out
that weapon crafting is this crazy thing
the day of because there's like moments
right like what are some examples of
stuff they didn't tell us that were game
play where when it happened we were
doing all the time
did they add swords without telling us
and we found out during the taking king
that was in the game that's that's my
memory they always do it i mean they
shot the back for dead they they always
it's this
history we have with this game where we
have this push pull and we get upset yo
what are they doing whatever whatever
and they i always say they kind of give
you the bad news a little bit before the
expansion to get you ready and then soon
as that marketing trailer and them
bullet oh that's why oh my god this was
crazy it's the cycle we we we've been
here we're veterans we know you know i
said but to transport the e i think he
do gotta relax you gotta relax a little
bit you gotta you play
banner yeah i am better than got him in
the state but i know how he is about
armor sandbox and gameplay mechanics and
to leave something unfinished with e
it's not gonna sit well so he's probably
like yo don't even tell me at all if
you're gonna give me the complete
picture because otherwise i would get
frustrated because i don't have
confidence in you based on other things
you guys they could have literally left
this part of the 12
saved a whole lot of like issues on
twitter and everything else and they
could have just done like here's all
here's what we're going to tell you
about weapon crafting some secret like
you'll learn more when you get in there
also by the way
and then they could tie it in and give
you like there will be something and
wefting crap and that alleviates this
and just like bam like just why did it
have to come here
what if it's amazing what if like
traffic what if it's amazing then i
wouldn't be going through this at all
right now anyway you gotta you gotta
give it an apology dude
is amazing the same energy you going in
now yeah if it's
amazing i'm
[Laughter]
if the crafting is epic how's that
i hope you have fun is there anything
else with regards to the information
that we got this week whether it was the
trailer or there was the twab whether
it's anything you've seen like i think
bungie's doing their tweeting bungie
again thing going on right now so
they're excited again something's going
on at the studio or promo stuff that
they're seeing on the inside is there
anything else that i feel like i haven't
discussed this week that you guys want
to talk about whether it was
hi anything no because they were
tweeting just real quick they were
tweeting again about they were yelling
out for the rafters bungie again yeah
they were being going on really i missed
it when did this happen
during the show
i also saw somebody um tweet that they
now understand why bungie employees
shout bungie sometimes
that's what they have right
now
this ain't our first rodeo y'all we did
the ups and downs of being a destiny fan
we know how this goes
and i am curious to see you know the
next 12 what's happening and then once
that hype train rolls we're in you know
how it goes and i want some log i'm i'm
going to see i want i can't wait to see
where this thing happens
first day stream is gonna be like all
right let's see what happens in this
story and we're gonna play through it
and see what the hell happens so
well that is about all i've got as we
kind of head to the outro part of the
show i kind of want to to pass the floor
to you lucy um if you've got anything
that you got you know if you're going to
be streaming upcoming for which queen if
you're working on any content if you got
any cool like what's your big nasa
project or any cool stuff you're just
like fill our brains with what's going
on with your in your world as we wrap
the show up oh
okay i guess i can do that um
so like
i kind of a funny stuff not really funny
story well i used to stream
a lot back in like college because i was
like oh i have free time okay i'll just
stream and
then it kind of like my schedule and
then with the pandemic having to move
back in with my parents
kind of was like oh streaming can be on
hold well
i
think yeah i think i'm gonna stream the
witch like witch queen i'm gonna start
streaming again
so that's exciting i just need to like
sit down and like really think like
what's my brand like kind of i want to
like take it seriously but like
i think that might have been my problem
in the beginning as i was taking it too
seriously when i think i think the
problem is is like
it's okay just to do things for fun yes
not everything has to be super serious
and that's my problem i go either 0 or
100 no in between i can't take things
sort of seriously it's either
super uber serious or
i don't care
it's it's like one end of the spectrum
or this one all or nothing um
pretty much pretty much it's either okay
i'm all in or i don't care
zero [ __ ] were given
and there's three but yeah
yeah
oh what everybody there you ain't quiet
yeah we're here okay everybody got quite
good
i'm sorry
no i was just
yeah i don't really think i
have anything else to say except uh
thank you guys for having me you guys
are super great yeah you're awesome you
guys are great you've come here
now you're awesome salute to you i love
anytime we get a chance to really deep
dive with the lore and and talk to
someone just as passionate about it and
getting us some gems and details it's
always exciting love what you're doing
out here and uh yeah we got to get you
back that this was a fun show you got to
see our ridiculousness live
pleasure to have you for sure
yeah
trav what's going on with you man yeah
uh yeah i think um last time i was on
the show i told you guys
i got my first uh three ign reviews for
the year lined up um
i'm i'm reviewing uh windjammers two my
review of that will go up january 20th
um and then i'm also reviewing crossfire
x which comes out on february 10th and
then uh
destiny to the witch queen i'm reviewing
for ign yeah which that review will go
up probably the day after the raid once
i've beaten it presumably so uh fun
stuff for that but something actually
funny happened this week which was um i
spent like the last
seven or eight days laughing at that uh
post that the dying light 2 developers
posted where they said the game was
going to take 500 hours to complete i
could not stop talking about that i was
laughing about it i was i was messaging
friends and dms about it i was telling
people in my life like dude they just
got flamed for telling the people that
this game was going to be 500 hours
could not stop laughing about it and
then i found out this week
due to a series of unfortunate events
that i will be reviewing dying light too
i will be playing the 500 hour game and
writing the review and uh i think karma
if you ever had any doubt that karma
exists it certainly exists because i'm
uh i'm i'm definitely reading what i've
sowed in this category um but anyway um
yeah i'm gonna be busy this these next
couple months with the reviews and
obviously i'm very very excited to
review the witch queen um for ign um and
you can follow me on twitter at ty guy
travis uh if you really really hate
yourself um and you also can uh
you can see me every sunday at uh 8 a.m
pacific on a show called bitcast which
you can find on youtube at bigcast and
uh you should follow my friends here you
should uh
talk to cog he'll sell you a a headset
on twitter all day he's just selling
people headsets so he's a door-to-door
salesman now with that
yeah
would you like to try out our new quest
too yeah yeah he shows up with a suit
and tie on your door hello hi
have you heard the good news
oh no he's taken after his family
anyway
yeah
it's great man um so and then and then
yeah you should follow e he's got a
great video right now that i tweeted yes
please
about uh things to do to prepare for the
witch queen and how to grind materials
it's fantastic everybody should watch
that video three times and then like it
on four different alt accounts and then
share it uh
on uh 8-chan i don't know where the kids
go these days anyway that should be
changing here all week cute
that's how you go viral
lucy pull it out big fun
great show i guess shout out to the chat
we had like almost 150 y'all in it hit
that like button y'all this was a real
fun show really good topics um yeah you
know me laura cognito on twitter
shout out to
travis clown and me for selling oculus
since people hit me up like yo i got one
because timeline is just you selling
people oculus like i'm so confused
people hit me up like bro because you i
got one now that you're over there
salute to everybody that is what's up
but um yeah man this was a lot of fun
we're getting closer finally to witch
queen i'm excited shout out to everybody
in the chat i will be on so i see uh i
see dj i see citizens i see back there's
some clan mates i'm going to jump on
after i got i got to get in there man i
got me hyped got to do some homework got
to do some more stuff but also check out
ireland's podcast this sunday we will
have mama micah on she will be on to
talk from last stand media we'll get to
talk about gaming nice everything that's
going on also shout out to uh
definitely duke me and maddie been
working really hard we have one up right
now just going on what's going on with
tencent and then we gotta what i i can
talk about was we just recorded um from
drinkbox studios um nobody saves the
world cool game coming out next week i
believe also launching in the game pass
developer was awesome we got to talk to
him about the structure of indie games
and and how that is to get for a little
you know studio they also made
guacamelee you know those guys so um
yeah they did pretty awesome yeah and it
was a great discussion that should be
coming out next week so maddie i didn't
break it in here we should be fine but
um yeah and that said of course the last
word we're still doing this having fun e
congratulations you're grinding you're
moving i'm seeing bungie
loving your guides and he's a big star
out here travis last week
he called me hollywood i don't get
bungee tweeting
he's tweeting his stuff he's gonna be
like sponsored it's gonna it's great man
bandscaped and
a celebrity superstar oh my god no stop
um
no just trying to work on a little bit
of the backlog i know monster hunter
eyes just came out i'll probably might
play that here there i really do want to
knock out um horizon
um just because that's a big one and the
other one i want to do is i want to see
if i can get through just dark souls 1
before
the week of february hell
so my goal between downtime
and
just like keeping up with what's going
on in this game and keeping content
going
depending on the pacing what the way
things are going we might see 70k subs
next week knock on wood
so that would be that'd be cool um but
thank you guys seriously for all the
support all of you guys in chat this is
our biggest show on youtube thank you
guys um so spread the word tell your
friends if you enjoy the show yeah lucy
brought the numbers she seriously she
made it happen yeah made it happen this
is all lucy we appreciate it and
honestly thank you lucy for coming on
for talking lore
in being uh the smartest one on the
podcast by a large margin no no
and um and seriously just like and and
putting up with our three
ridiculousnesses so we appreciate your
your time travis we um
we know it's not gonna quite be like
nerf legends but we do hope you make it
through yes the dying light review
yes please see what i did there
i like it and then cog of course uh make
sure and use promo code cognito at
metta.com for your quest to purchase
yeah lucy killed it seriously but as we
wrap this show up as always chat you
guys have been amazing thank you follow
all of these amazing people
if lucy when lucy does stream make sure
and tune in blow up her first stream so
it's amazing and she barely knows what
to do
oh yeah no seriously follow her please
follow lady lucita on twitter i want her
first stream like 50 60 chats just like
scrolling come on we gotta make
everything oh god that's awesome that
sounds stressful
yeah to the moon to the moon there you
go see it fits for you though
yeah you guys are great all right well
thank you all very much we will be
wrapping this thing up january 13th
[Laughter]
cognito does have a referral link we
will post that on all of his socials uh
don't worry we will copy that one and
use it everywhere so thank you use the
code sell out to save twenty percent on
your office platform
use code got the bag at checkout
[Laughter]
thank you guys for the record numbers
and hopefully we just keep going up but
for now
you guys have been awesome and for this
episode it has been
the last word